this is a production of Cornell
University
so good morning everyone welcome to
plant science 4950 senior capstone
seminar symposium Mike Scanlon and I are
thrilled to host everyone today I am
Chris smart one of the co instructors
for the course and I will be the
official timekeeper keeping us on time
because we know people are going to hop
in and off today my introduce yourself
and get us started
hi I'm Mike Scanlon my biology I co
teach this course with Chris as you just
said yeah I get we have a great lineup
today so I think we'll just get started
our first speaker is Martino Koch she's
an ex high and international agriculture
and rural development major who's
concentrating in sustainable cropping
systems after graduating she's planning
on staying for a PhD right here at
Cornell and plant breeding with Mike
Mazurek and the title of our talk today
is the future of carbs if you can share
your screen money we can launch this
all right good morning everybody
so I want to start you guys off for the
question how many people listening out
there like bread or other carbs can
raise your hand all right I see quite a
few hands out there so statistically
five percent of you carb eaters have
some sort of wheat sensitivity and the
biggest culprit for these wheat
sensitivities are api's and ATI stands
for alpha amylase trypsin inhibitor and
these wheat sensitivities range on a
pretty broad spectrum which can go on
the low side of issues which you might
just have some stomach discomfort when
you need carbohydrates all the way to
having pretty severe allergic reactions
and through evolution 80 eyes have been
an insect defense mechanism
so basically when the insect nibbles on
the kernels of wheat and ingests the
ATIS
it inhibits digestive enzymes from
breaking down starches into maltose or
other simple sugars the insects can't
obtain nutrients from the food they're
eating and they die so it's a pretty
great mechanism for wheat and other
small grains problem is you still have
these issues when people eat small grain
products but there's hope for people who
have these wheat sensitivities because a
tea eyes are rarely used in the
beginning of determination so as part of
my honors thesis I looked at how we
could use germination as a
pre-processing technique guys so what we
did was we took two different wheat
cultivars and we did petri dish
terminations at several times
temperature and pH values and we use
this DNS technique which uses three five
Dino Dino nitro silicic acid and
basically this acid creates a color
indicator so when you add your enzymes
to the wheat sample the more maltose
start has broken down into maltose the
darker your
sample is so over here in this picture
you can see this darker sample as more
it starts broken down the maltose than
this letter color sample over here and
we can take these colored samples and
indirectly measure maltose using like
spectrometry and we can use this
equation here putting in our absorbance
reading and we get the maltsters
expected and we can indirectly know how
much ATIS are left in the sample
depending how much maltose was released
so more maltose means less api's in the
sample better for us so when we first
looked at time we looked at a range of
periods from 12 to 48 hours and what we
found was there's this kind of sweet
spot where you get a high level maltose
release right here at the 36 and 40 two
hour time point before you start getting
the presence of shoots and roots which
decreases the quality of the grain to be
used in other products so we found that
overall we like this 36 hour time point
for having low amount of roots but
having a high enough release of maltose
that we know we're getting our HDI
levels low enough it's not going to
cause problems to people wheat
sensitivities
and then we looked at the effects of
temperature so we looked at 20 30 and 40
degrees Celsius and what we found was at
20 degrees Celsius which was about room
temperature for us in the laboratory
even though there was quite a bit of
variability here in the maltose release
overall moto statistic was significantly
higher in all the 20 degrees samples we
also found at least 30 and 40 degrees
temperature samples that we had a lot of
mold and issues with germination which
obviously when you start having low
germination and you start having mold
and things we can't use these products
these wheat product for our other
products so overall we decided that is
20
in degree timing or temperature point
sorry was the best for germination and
lastly we looked at the effect of pH
also release and what we did here was a
two key test and basically well the two
key test does is it takes your
measurement for each variable you're
looking at and it tells you they're
significantly different from each other
and it gives you a letter that
corresponds to a significant difference
group and what we found here is that
these acidic pH is of three four and
five we did not see any significant
difference between maltose release as we
see all three columns have an a so at
least at these temperatures
pH ranges we didn't really see a affect
from pH so our conclusions from this
part of my study is that the optimal
germination conditions seem to be about
36 degrees or 36 hours at 20 degrees
Celsius pH does not seem to have much
impact on germination and maltose
release and there's possibility for
future or food science and human
nutrition research to use this
determination as a pre-processing step
to make wheat products for people who
have wheat sensitivities and lastly I
would like to thank Cornell University's
small grains breeding program for
helping me with this project and the
special thanks to dr. mark Sarles James
Tanaka and Daniel Sweeney for helping
thank you are there any questions as a
fantastic job Marly really well done and
thank you so much for leading us off
okay our next talk is from rosemary
gloss a plant science major with a minor
in botanical illustration and her
concentration is evolution in
systematics after graduation and ROS
will be taking a gap year before
entering the Graduate School of her
choice probably and then today her title
is investigating leaflet and a comical
variation in the leaf cycad genus is a
Mia
great thank you very much Mike and thank
you everyone for tuning in to the
symposium today
today I'm going to talk about my senior
thesis project in the spectra where I
looked at leaflet anatomical variation
in a rather charismatic group of cycads
just start us up I'd like to just remind
everyone of what exactly a psych ad is I
would hate to think anyone had forgotten
but just in case cycads are gymnosperms
so they fall in the tree with other
plants that produce seeds but not
flowers such as conquerors and ginkgo
etc and cycads have the unfortunate
distinction of being the most threatened
order of plants on earth and because of
this or maybe despite that we have some
surprising gaps in our knowledge about
cycads and whenever we don't know enough
about something basic as Anatomy or mark
follow G for a group of plants we have a
hard time defining species and therefore
understanding how many species we have
to conserve so from my own project I
actually had two goals a scientific one
and a personal one the scientific one is
the one I'll focus on today and that's
just filling in a gap in our knowledge
of cycad anatomy but I don't want to
neglect the personal way the personal
one is for me as a senior hoping to go
to graduate school staring to design
implement and communicate some original
research and that second goal is just as
important and perhaps even more
important than the second the first one
so what did I do well I'd like to frame
my research question by speaking
specifically to the resources that have
been available to me because this
project would not have been possible
without them so in the center here is my
research question it asks our anatomical
characters phylogenetically informative
in the genus zania i'm focusing on the
genus is a meow because it's the largest
cycad genus in the new world and also it
has a surprising paucity of anatomical
information in the literature and sort
of by asking whether we can use
anatomical characters to define clades
within the phylogeny we have a better
idea of how many species that are how
they're related and therefore how we can
conserve them in order to ask this
question I need a file
framework unfortunately I have a newly
published by La Janine found out by
Michael : he and his collaborators so I
have the framework I need and then I
also need the actual plant material to
compare it to that framework so in
January I went down to Coral Gables
Florida and I collected material at the
Montgomery Botanical Center and
Fairchild tropical botanic garden and
then now that I had the material and the
framework I needed the means to actually
section image and prepare all of those
slides and for that I had an in-house
Anatomy collection in lab and that's a
hundred Gandolfo slab and the Cornell
University plant Anatomy question lastly
I needed expertise because when I
started this project I didn't actually
know how to do any of these things I
didn't know how to properly prepare
slides or really look at an anatomical
section so I'm very thankful to all the
members of the spec lab in particular
Chelsey spec and Shayla Salsman and also
Barry Tomlinson and Alex anatomist at
Harvard who was absolutely instrumental
and helping me get started so I would
love to have sampled and examined every
single species in this genus
but it's just not tenable many of them
are not a cultivation and even if they
were I just didn't have a time I'm
afraid to look at every single one so
instead I chose twenty out of the eighty
ones name yes species plus an out group
then a fairly good broad phylogenetic
and geographic distribution across the
genus the circular phylogeny on the
bottom here sure those the samples that
I chose in green and as in the whole
it's the whole phylogeny of the species
so this just sure of the genus so this
just shows that the ones I sample have
pretty good representation across the
major claims on the right here is a
pared down phylogeny showing just the
species that I chose along with their
geographic distribution and this
distribution closely matches that of the
genus as a whole
I don't have the time unfortunately to
go into all the details of what I did to
prepare my samples but it fell into
roughly four categories I started by
collecting all the samples down in
Florida I collected
individual leaflets after off larger
compound leaves and I fixed them in FAA
and stored them in ethanol and then back
at Alejandra's lab I sectioned them on a
rotary microtome I stained them with a
wide variety of stains that specifically
elucidate certain characters of the
anatomy specifically safranin fluid I'm
blue Sudan for and others and then I
examined them under a compound
microscope and scored them for a wide
range of anatomical characters that bear
it across the chance and so today I'd
like to just show you some of my initial
results starting with what the leaflets
look like as a whole so this circular
phylogeny here shows nearly all of the
species in the genus these were all of
the ones I was able to find on in
Florida the main gaps are predominantly
Amazonian species that have only been
recently described and all I want you to
take away from this giant graph is that
there's a whole lot of variation in this
genus the leaflets are thick or thin or
long or short some are variegated but
thing is if you look at it they don't
cluster and similar with similar
characters so it's not as if all of the
long thin ones are in one plate or a
really good one to look at is the
placate leaves the ones that are folded
and they don't all fall together either
however there has been some other work
showing that Anatomy could potentially
be more informative machinist and so
there may be anatomical characters that
correspond to certain slides so that's
what I love done and in order to show
you this I'm going to walk you through
what a general cross section of a zania
leaflet looks like just in case it's
been in a while since you've looked at
an Anatomy slide so this is a
cross-section of Xenia blue Vienna
stained with safranin I'm just gonna
walk you through what we're seeing here
so below the cuticle which you can't
quite see in this image because it's not
being stained is an epidermis and then
beneath the epidermis is usually ass
clarified hypodermis that may be
discontinuous or continuous and may even
be several layers depending on the taxon
and then what you see below that depends
on whether you're in between a vascular
bundle
or above a vascular bundle in between
you have the palisade mesophyll where a
lot of photosynthesis takes place and
then the spongy mesophyll and if you're
above a vascular bundle you see what's
called in a literature a girder
sclerenchyma and really that's just a
cluster of fibers above and also below
the vascular bundle and then the
masculine bundle itself has the xylem
and phloem and then there's that other
girders for income and the abaxial
epidermis and there are a few other
characters I saw as well that varied the
presence of these Druce crystals for one
and then also these fibers that would
either be in the bundle sheath or
scattered throughout the mesophyll and I
saw both sweater hide fibers and
cellulosic fibers so that's an
introduction to what a typical
cross-section looks like and so most
species I saw had most of these
characters in some form or another so
what did that variation look like well I
said I looked at 20 species so I saw a
lot of variation and I just like to
point out some key things on this
relatively busy slide so on the left
here are just two images of the margins
of leaflets and you can see that the
sheep varies quite a bit the presence of
that girders for incomer also varies and
this species on top Oliviana it's there
but in this one on the bottom it's not
and also in this top one they an axial
hypodermis it's continuous there's a
single layer and in the bottom it has
gaps if you look at the center and look
at this these species with the red boxes
you'll notice that in some species the
girders flooring Kamiya is completely
absent in the middle of the leaflet and
in others it's quite small and in others
it's even bigger and I tried to control
four possible effects of age by always
going to the center of the leaflet and
always choosing mature leaves and on the
right here it's this is just a reminder
that there are a few species that are
flying those fool disease and that has
its own effect on the morphology of the
vasculature and the surrounding fibers
but remember my question was not whether
there is the variation in this in this
genus my question is whether that there
is phylogenetics way informative so
let's take a look at that well here is a
peered down version of my final matrix I
look I looked at a lot more characters
than yes but there's a few and the
bottom line is that just like leaflet
morphology there's actually not very
many phylogenetically informative
characters they tend to be spread across
the phylogeny with no discernible
pattern and so these characters outlined
in right here show no such pattern
however I would like to talk about one
particular character and that's these
cells that I'm in formally calling flat
tires because I actually don't know
exactly what they are
I talked to anatomist Barry Tomlinson
there's a thought that they may have
some secretory function because of the
extensive plasmid estimate all
connections between them and their
neighboring cells with the key thing for
the purpose of my research is that they
only show up in this play down here
consisting of the isthmus species South
American species and this odd ones amias
open the census initially I thought it
was diagnostic for this clade actually
but it turns out they pop up a couple of
times out of it so I would like to look
into this character more to determine
their function and composition and also
to do some additional sectioning to see
if they actually are only distributed in
this plate and to determine really what
their their ultimate distribution is so
where does this leave us is anatomical
variation really very helpful in
determining relationships between
species in this genus well there's
definitely variation it's there but
based on my initial survey it looks like
most of that variation is homo placeless
and scattered across the phylogeny
however there are a few characters those
quote-unquote flat tires included that
may be unique to certain clays and it
all begs the question of where their
Anatomy might actually be more dependent
on ecology than phylogeny in other words
it's possible that the variation I'm
seeing has more to do with what sort of
habitat a species lived in than their
phylogenetic relationships and so
certainly begs another question and
invites further research into whether
there's an association between
anatomical characters in this genus and
the many different habitats they grow in
I'd like to wrap up with some final
acknowledgments you've heard many of the
people who have been really instrumental
to this project but I'd like to send a
final shout out to the spec lab Sheila
salesmen in particular dr. Barry
Tomlinson and a whole host of other
people including my funding sources the
castle on my association and the Dexter
undergraduate research endowment and I
want to thank all of you for tuning in
this morning for the symposium you have
many more talks ahead of you and thank
you very much I'd be happy to take
questions any questions for Rosie
this is Marga I have a question so if
taxonomist haven't been able to use or
haven't used anatomical traits to
separate species and families what
traits do they use and the psychedelia
is to determine what's a genus and was a
family gross morphological traits that
are helpful such as productive
structures there are also some finer
traits having to do with mediums as a
whole the shapes of the leaves and the
presence of spines patio and then more
recently the vast majority of the
phylogenetic work in cycads is done with
molecular phylogenies
including Michael Columbus thanks that
was a really great presentation so if
these things aren't related to phylogeny
if they are consequences of the
environment what are the characteristics
of the environment that give rise to
these different anatomical features that
you're seeing what are some of the
variations that could give rise to the
presence or absence of the the ribs or
whatever you call those things
yeah well the genus has a very wide
geographic distribution in many
different habitats and the one that pops
immediately to mind when you ask that
question is Xenia pseudo parasitic ax
which is actually the only
epiphytic member of this genus and it
also happens to me the member that has
the most of those unusual cells in it
and so as an epithet ik plant the first
thing that pops into mind for me is that
it has to deal a lot with water stress
and so I don't know yet if there's an
association between the presence of
those cells and some improved capacity
to contain water but that's potential
Avenue of inquiry I heard nothing okay
great concert great job okay
well done Rosie
it's great our next speaker is olivia
gomez and she's concentrating in plant
pathology and she'll continue this
interest pursuing a PhD next fall at
Washington University in st. Louis in
the Department of plant and micro
Biosciences the title of our talk today
is biofilm in the rhizosphere Olivia
right well I'm here to present the
research I've done last summer in the
Donald Danforth Plant Science Center so
I'll start by introducing the root
microbiome it's essentially the
collection of all the microbes
associated with plant root and this can
be divided into the end of sphere the
inside of the root the rhizosphere this
just the soils immediately surrounding
the root and then the soil is a little
bit further away and the point is a
healthy microbiome leads to healthy
plant longer and just more extensive and
this leads to joint resistance which is
of interest in systems and many bacteria
in the wild form biofilm which is a
special growth habit that allows
bacteria to live communally on a surface
usually starts with a few individual
sticking and then the colony grows and
as it grows and it disperses and the
cycle repeats itself in a previous study
arab adopts uh seedlings were grown in
agar plates and there were different
treatments that were subjected to
different mixtures of bacteria make sure
a showed root growth comparable to that
of the control which had nothing i make
sure be as you can see has a shorter
route for you know type than the control
but when you mix mixture a and b you can
see a rescuing of the short word
phenotype it's comparable to that of the
control if even a little bit longer and
so what really intrigues us is what is
causing its rescue
the phenotype so the mixtures were
sequenced and the predominant genus of
bacteria found in mixture a at the end
of this treatment was very rax well and
mixture be the predominant genus is Agra
bacteria streams so the main question is
what accounts for these phenotypes why
is it that there are different route
links based on the different mixture of
bacteria and what is causing this
rescuing of the short route phenotype
when you mix the two mixtures together
the hypothesis is that biofilm
production is what leads to the short
route phenotype in literature you find
that very rocks for the most part
doesn't form a biofilm well I grow
bacterial strains do and the idea is
that the very rock strings that will not
form biofilm may disrupt agrovoc - you
have biofilm production and this might
be what is causing the rescuing of the
short route phenotype so I was entrusted
with 17 I'll go back to histories and 11
very rock strains these were all from
sorghum fields in the industry
rhizosphere in surrounding soil because
it is hoped that this research will be
applied to sorghum in the future and so
I measured the bathroom production each
individual string as well as
combinations of different strains in
vitro so to summarize my findings there
were I found both bathroom lacking and
by from producing either bacterium this
is already contrary to the hypothesis we
only thought there that there would be
biofilm forming tiger bacteria similarly
I found both both from producing as well
as about from lacking very rocks we only
thought that there would be about
belphin lacking very rocks and so
because we had these four different
categories here are all the different
kinds of interactions I could observe I
made many different combinations and I
found some pretty surprising results I
categorize it
front interactions as either synergistic
or they build each other up disruptive
or neutral and so that one of the
surprising interactions I found was that
back from lacking agar bacteria can
actually disrupt a baffle producing agar
bacterial biofilm secondly another
surprising finding is that bow from
lacking I grow bacteria can disrupt the
bow from producing very rocks this is
the actual complete opposite of what the
hypothesis predicted and thirdly another
above another surprising interaction is
that that from producing very rocks can
actually have a synergistic effect with
each other but there's actually a
greater amount of biome produced when
you mix them together here are the
different other interactions that I've
observed but they mostly fall into the
predicted or predictable pattern so in
summary Buffone production of Iraq's and
I'll go back to you is not so clear-cut
there are some very rocks that can
produce or lack biofilm and there's a
grow bacteria that can form or lock back
home as well secondly each general has
the potential to disrupt the other so in
ain't based on these data I would not
account biofilm 2 to be responsible for
the different root phenotypes that we've
observed and lastly more studies are
needed because this is all done in vitro
we don't know what really happens in
vivo I'd like to thank dr. Ming Cheng
Chi who was my postdoc advisor hi dr.
Becky Bart who welcomed me into her lab
all the part lab for all their help and
the coordinators Donald Danforth Plant
Science Center and NSF for funding thank
you great job
yeah okay our next talk is from
Christian kin lien when Christian is a
plant science major with a minor in
Community Food Systems he's also
designed his own concentration in urban
food systems after graduation
Christian hopes to secure a job at
headwater food hub as a produce manager
in Rochester he'll keep us posted on
that and the title of his presentation
is reflections on controlled environment
agriculture Christian thanks Mike
yeah so my name is Christian and today
I'm going to talk about some thoughts
about growing food in cities in
controlled environments there we go okay
so I'm sure you guys noticed lots of
humans are living in cities now and that
means they have really little connection
with it where their food comes from and
how it gets to them despite the fact
that abundant research shows that
especially when you teach kids how food
is grown that they make much healthier
decisions you throughout their entire
life and recently there's been huge
venture capital investment on both
coasts in the sort of technology and
growing food in controlled environments
and so it's important to be able to read
beyond the headlines a little bit and
see if these companies are really living
up and doing what they say they're doing
and so I spent two summers in New York
City the first working with middle and
high school students at the Food &
Finance high school and the Police
Athletic League in Harlem and so they
were growing lettuce and herbs and
vegetables that were be used in their
culinary arts program which is really
cool and then the following summer I was
at a small consulting firm in Brooklyn
architecture and in addition to you
helping with their consulting work I've
put together and distributed a survey
with three other Cornell interns at
different CA companies across New York
City and we surveyed the whole spectrum
of growing technology in the city all
the way from outdoor soil based all the
way to indoor fully supplemental light
and I want to stress that there's no
real right or wrong amount of Technology
to use when you're growing food it just
depends on what you want to grow and
firm and what we found is that people
don't like answering ad question long
surveys they take an hour 1/2
so we didn't get that many responses but
we asked some more qualitative answers
and so a lot of these insights are drawn
from some anecdotes and some longer
answers that people provided us one of
the strongest things we found is that
people growing food in cities consider
themselves as more than just growers
they see themselves as part of the
community sort of like I mentioned
earlier providing that connection with
where food is grown and how it gets to
people and all sorts of nutrition
education associated with that and then
we also surveyed packaging from a lot of
these companies and what we found is
that they really downplay the technology
that is used in growing even if they
invested millions and millions of
dollars in putting it together and we
sort of speculated that that's because
people already have associations with
words like local and organic and
pesticide free and so that's what
they're looking for when they shop
rather than green house grown hydroponic
growing soil is you know so that was
sort of interesting and next time you're
at the grocery store I encourage you to
take a look at that especially if you
ever see lettuce with the roots still on
because that means it was grown
hydroponically and some of my lingering
thoughts about this are again around
what is being grown in for whom the
socio-economic divide and accessibility
of these crops those indoor facilities I
mentioned in the first slide that you
have done all that investment I focused
on leafy greens and herbs microgreens
even that have a really high turnover
but have to be priced at a really
inaccessible point to be able to recoup
the huge capital investment so if we're
talking about feeding people or feeding
cities that's real realistically that's
not it and then one of the other things
is around labor and to the processors I
worked on or working around curriculum
to develop sort of two-year programs
that can get people into this workforce
because there's a real shortage of
people doing this work now I want to
highlight two great organizations that I
surveyed and met the owners of okhla
arms in Brooklyn which grows not just
the vegetables featured here but also
fish in an aquaculture system which is
great because it's more closed-loop less
inputs more sustainable and then sky'
vegetables in the Bronx that hires
formerly incarcerated people and people
from the community that and so with that
I'd like to thank Neil Matson and on
your honor
on new Rangarajan the two professors I
was supervised by as well as white
Marshall and my idiom the two grad
students who helps us with the survey
design and Mason Brian and Kat my fellow
interns who are those other SEO
companies any questions hmm Christian
questions so this is Marvin again what's
current thinking about so the energy
inputs and outputs of some of these
closed systems of indoor lighting it's a
great question a lot of these companies
claim to be sustainable or you know sort
of but you could make it our game to
probably about water but certainly not
about energy inputs and people even
talking about doing like solar panels
but you need five acres of solar panels
for every acre of indoor greenhouse and
25 acres for every acre of point
factories of Stax completely artificial
lighting
so it's certainly in terms of energy
it's not and more sustainable thank you
still we get fusion power okay other
questions
nice presentation great job Christian
okay moving forward our next talk is
from Jennifer King and Jennifer is a
plants and human health concentrator
she's hoping to apply to graduate school
and pursue her interest in botany and
the title of her presentation is her
barrier for the modern-day botanist um
so it's a collection of giant post plant
specimens I'm the first one um first I
barium was started in 16th century by
Italian botanist
I'm sunshine it's grown considerably and
the largest collection is the National
Museum of Natural History at Paris
France and it has over 8 million
specimens however recently there's been
threats to the funding which has had a
long consolidation of collections so a
little bit about the Liberty high-bay
Ilya Toria on campus it was started in
1935 by Liberty High Bailey later merged
with other collections such as the see
you
Weidman collection in the botany
department it's called a hot area and
not on herbarium because it has origins
that started in horticulture specimens
right now we have a little over 900,000
specimens and we have strengths and Oaks
palms and legumes so I've had the
opportunity to work with on many
different Natural History Collection on
campus first we have the paleobotany
collection or I helped organize and
barcode the specimens we have the plant
Anatomy collection where I helped image
the slides and the conservatory where
I've helped create interactive QR codes
and then finally the herbarium where I
said the bulk of my time databasing and
imaging the specimens and all this work
has gone to curation work has gone to
efforts to help to preserve these
collections so some may see herbarium as
an outdated practice but it actually
holds a lot of modern-day importance
there's been a strong effort to do ties
and database these materials I've seen
to the right over here
the top is databasing and the bottom is
imaging all these material can help
further studies in identification and
morphology the old patterns climate
change a written record for nomenclature
there a place for researchers to deposit
doctor specimens and also material for a
chemical and DNA analysis so you may be
wondering how you create a specimen I'm
gonna walk you through the process of
what I've done to you to turn plants and
discuss amines two steps at a time first
you start off in the field collecting as
you can see from this picture right here
we're in a canoe collecting aquatic
plants so field collecting can take you
to my ATV terrain such as tops of
mountains in lakes and enforce when
choosing a plant it's best to find a
specimen that displays roots stems
leaves flowers and fruits in addition
y'all should be note taking out in the
field running down the locality habitat
plant descriptors and the date
shortly after with your specimen you
will dry and press it over here I mean
on the right you will
press it in newspaper and you want one
side of the bottom leaving one side of
top leaf at least showing you will dry
until all the moisture is gone usually
about one to two weeks
so moving on our next step is in put
your specimen in the freezer this is a
very important step which is sometimes
overlooked um it's important to put it
in the freezer because that kills any
pests or bugs that may be honest essence
but you don't want to get into the
herbarium which can eat the material
Wow your Sussman's in the freezer you
can go ahead and create the label you
will do this with your notes that data
that you took from the field
in addition you can use an economist
dichotomous key to officially properly
key out identify your specimen from
there um you're finally ready to mount
your specimen on archival people with
glue and linen and once that is dried
voila you have your very own specimen
that's ready for filing so some
takeaways that I've learned from my
experience at the Bailey hoard tour iam
I've learned skills of curation
digitization and methods in the field
collection
Bailey Hart areum and other herbarium
currently right now have strong pushes
and focuses on digitizing their
collections all to create a virtual
herbarium and this is an example of why
arborea still hold important value and
that they're evolving with science and
technology um my acknowledgments I like
to thank everyone at the Bailey Hyde
comport or iam in particular Kevin Anna
and Peter this concludes my presentation
thank you for listening great job
Jennifer any questions folks
we are a bit ahead of schedule Mike so
can I ask a question this is Chelsea
SPECT please Josey so so Jennifer I was
just wondering if you when you think
about all the work you got to do with
your barium what was the most intriguing
to you and what might you think about
pursuing as a graduate student um since
my concentration is in medicinal botany
I'm really curious about like the
chemical analysis you could do from
specimens and kind of I don't know
that's no botany side of that and what
they had they used the plants for
medicinal purposes like I want to focus
on that part great did you find any or
barium labels that had sort of ethno
botanical medicinal information not
directly on the label but I've kind of
helped create a little collection and
digitized some ones I like I personally
found that had been turned into like
pharmaceutical drugs and stuff so I did
my own kind of own research and then
found them out in the filing cabinets
great thank you thank you our next
presentation is from Emma Kaminski and
Emma is a plant sciences minor reminder
is in soil science your major is plant
science our concentration is ecology of
natural landscapes and the title of our
talk today is ecological restoration at
Dunn and Dagon State Historic Site okay
this morning we'll be talking about the
ecological restoration work I carried
out economic and State Historic Site
with new york state parks environmental
field team for the past five years we
had a few overarching goals that guided
our restoration work first we wanted to
restore the historical landscape back to
how it was when the honey Ashanti
happened at the site in the 1600 this
provides both ecological opportunities
and education we also want to restore
and maintain our ecological communities
capacity for self-sufficiency we want
identify short and long-term threats to
prepare accordingly we want to catalog
our biodiversity to preserve what we
already have and we want to promote
stewardship through education and
outreach to meet these goals we do three
main things my
invasive species control and the actual
restorative processes so the first
monitoring that we do is vegetation
surveys so these surveys that we carry
out our inner grasslands impaired with
grassland bird surveys these surveys
allow us to understand how they're
changing diversity and structure their
grassland as we refer them affect the
threatened bird species the other big
aspect of our monitoring is invasive
specie identify the location and density
of invasive species populations around
the park this takes up a big chunk of
our summer so it's really important to
recognize how critical this is to our
restoration work so an example this is
on the right this is in one of our
invasive species on-site aims rocket and
here is the map that are showing so as
you can see there's small population
sprinkled throughout the park because we
were able to tech them to detect them so
early we can rapidly respond and remove
these and bases before they could spread
and become more of a problem here's
another example this is probably work as
you can see over here we want to do
things like manual hand removal but in
places like this where the population is
still pretty widespread we want to turn
to things like chemical control so
shifting on their control methods as I
mentioned we do use chemical controls
because of the lens that we're working
with and it's just simply not having
enough people or time we do use
herbicides - we do use hand control as
much as we can and when it's needed from
one of our control methods is we carry
out prescribed burns um friends get rid
of invasives that are early sprouting in
the spring and also stimulate our native
warm-season grasses
it was also used by the
so awfully carry out these control
methods we have a pretty blank slate in
terms of plant community so one of the
things the environmental field team does
is we do native seed collection at our
local parks and natural areas I'm
collecting Carrick's Oriya or going
inside churches on my favorite plants we
then take these plants and we probably
ate them out in greenhouses and then use
them in our restoration planting after
we've managed to site so with all this
time and effort a really important
question to ask is is it working so
here's the years we've seen a
significant decline in council and then
to put another visual on it here's a pic
in 2016 of one of our graph that spells
World War II and all these grasses
non-natives
this is a picture I took right before I
left this summer and headed to school I
these biggest Tufts of grass are a bunch
of one season native grasses any paltrow
house well Wharton site I want to thank
the awesome people I worked with at the
environmental filthy and New York State
Park and Anand again for all the amazing
opportunities I was provided so this is
Marvin I have a question so like one of
your goals is to re-establish the site
similar to what the hottest Oney would
have seen at the time and it strikes me
that there's a lot of open field at the
site so do you know how much was
originally forest and how much does open
feel at the time it was sort of managed
by the how does sunny
that was Action Team 5 um there's
actually been a there was a recent study
published on where they think that there
was a lot of fees of grasslands and they
are throughout central New York so this
is a lot of them were considered oak
savannas so these grasslands and
naturally I guess you can say it with us
the age with an antenna right back
thanks other questions
uh of the control strategies you tried
chemical burn hand hand pulling which
which do you feel like was most
effective and definitely definitely to
play on the planet we controlled the
list go on in because it was so white
widespread it was probably the hardest
to get real I don't say we can work with
such large areas thanks I don't have a
very technical question but do you ever
foresee a time when this area will not
have to be constantly monitored you
think it will actually become a more
natural state eventually yeah that is
one of our one of our big overarching
goals is that we don't want have to have
to maintain these sites forever
or going to outlast outlast and because
we're also working in such big areas
we're trying to kind of make almost big
goals because it is great okay thank you
beautiful they have a lot of new guests
okay our next speaker is Alexander Liu
out sets of dual concentration in plant
pathology and plant computational
biology
after graduating from Cornell he will be
attending graduate school at Washington
University in st. Louis and today he'll
tell us about comparing drought response
in to c4 grasses using transcriptomic
analysis yep hello everyone today I will
be talking about the work I did at the
death bottle Danforth mine site sitter
in st. Louis this summer comparing john
swanson to c4 grasses using trace atomic
analysis so the projected climate in
2080 is expected to have an increase in
dry days and a decrease in soil moisture
all wrong and this will lead to
increased instances of drought and
longer instances of joe leading to more
drought stress plants which could lead
to more crop losses and so the goal of
this study was to identify drought
stress with genes and c4 grasses the two
species of grasses we were looking at
our superior varieties which is closely
related to c4 crops such as sorghum
amazing sugarcane and is also a model
organism and sorghum bicolor which is a
trap our c4 grass and is an important
food
to crowd both of these grasses that
their genome sequenced and are
relatively small have long and the short
lifespan looking easy to study so we
studied these plants in high throughput
phenotyping chamber the plants were
automatically watered and grown within
growth chamber and they would be taken
out via conveyor belt to be imaged
everyday for further analysis in
addition there is a so that -
phenotyping experiment we planted the
plants inside normal growth chambers and
after seven days we moved it to the
phenotype er and grew them for another
two weeks
where we began to drought treatment and
the drug treatment would be a water
deficit condition where the plants were
only watered to 40% of their soil water
capacity and we had a well water
treatment which is the control where the
plants were water to 85% of sorrel
autocracy and after we began to get
treatment we took leaf samples roughly
every two days until their two weeks
after the treatment begins and for each
species of grass we planted three
separate new types each treated in the
world model deficit treatment and well
water treatment and for each for each
treatment we had four replicates each
where we took leaf samples from three
plants and combined them and these leaf
samples were then the RNA was extracted
from them and sent off for three five
our innocence and so all that was done
before I actually arrived at the Denver
Center in the summer
and so my project was to develop I
already seek analysis pipeline and so
this the general flow this pipeline
would be to take the raw data quality
control and filter it for both like bad
low quality reads and also low quality
samples and then take the data and do
different searching expression analysis
on it and then after that to compare
compare differentially expressed genes
within the species and finally look for
conserved gene expression patterns
between sorghum isset area and so for
our quality control filtering step we
did the principal component analysis and
this basically reduces the thousands of
gene expression data and collapsed the
data to a to a chart where you can kind
of visualize it easily and for the
differential gene expression analysis we
use two packages
dc2 and edge dart which we then compared
to see which one was most ideal for car
analysis so looking at the principal
component analysis we found that we
could easily distinguish the three
separate genotypes of sorghum year and
in citerior we could distinguish we can
also distinguish the differing genotypes
although the 810 and DB 1248 are
clustered more or less together the more
interesting thing is you see these
separate dots over here which should
correspond with the clustering with
their respective clusters down here they
do not and we think these are probably
samples that we that were mixed up
during the the like sampling process
with the plants
so or they were planted incorrectly at
the very beginning since we're working
with hundreds of plants at a time
mistakes happen and this is why the
quality control step is so important but
it's also shows that the superior data
is overall more noisy since the cluster
is not defined and we also expected that
the clusters would hopefully also appear
when we compare drought treated plants
to non-drive treated plants which was
not the case
something that was interesting was that
if you look at the if you labeled the
samples by the date that they were taken
it appears that the you know the younger
samples were would cluster together and
then followed by a middle aged ones
followed by the older ones
now assuring that there is basically the
plant the the samples were clustered
more by developmental time this was
evident in both store government and
cetera and this is interesting because
you know especially in Soteria the
plants are relatively small and I had
very very fast life standing they could
flower and like a weeks and so over the
to experiment they would go from to
leave this evening to flower in by the
end and so moving on to the differential
gene expression analysis we first
focused on global drought response
across all genotypes so we were looking
for genes that were differentially
expressed between all three varieties of
sorghum Citterio
we found that HR tended to find a lot
more differentially expressed genes than
BC - this is especially evident in
Soteria where Dec to find any expression
differentially expressed genes until day
14 and sorghum though
numbers of differentially expressed
genes using the two found using the two
packages are more similar and there are
a decent number differentially expressed
genes are found by both packages and so
after looking at differential
differential gene expression within
species we wanted to compare the
differential gene expression between the
two species and so we called earth Mart
list with Argos genes between sorghum
Soteria off GGI
there were 26,000 North larvae in that
spreadsheet and we want to focus on
their early driver spots which would be
somewhere we you know we characterized
it as somewhere around day 60 a time
point where there's the first peak is
evident and since the ec2 didn't find
any differentially expressed genes in
that area we could only use a jar to do
this comparison so basically we took the
you know the genes that were different
to express the sorghum and citerior and
found the genes that are differentially
expressed in both and so there is that
pretty evident peak at the 8 in this
case with around 30 genes and so in
summary the gene expression seems to be
affected mostly by genotype and the Dom
of the age of the planet when I was
sampling plants for a later experiment a
more scaled up experiment
it seemed that these plants were not
particularly dressed dressed they were
you know both treatments came out green
and there's no leaf rolling so i'm
workstream shock treatments probably
needed there's a peach and
differentially expressed genes and
somewhere between 16 a
some future directions with the
clustering and network analysis of the
differentially expressed genes and the
lab is currently applying the pipeline
to a larger thing and typing experiment
with 94 varieties and three and we'll be
using full transcript RNA sequence
instead of the primary and the last
thing we could do would be to combine
the RNA seek theater metabolomic Steven
and I'd like to thank the dog Dan for
the plant Science Center and a safari
you program for having me allowing me to
work at intern there during the summer
and dr. Allan Poe birth mentoring me and
dr. Ivan Baxter in his lab for having
thank you I have a question so when you
say you want to do more severe drought
response I mean as a developmental
biologist we're often criticized because
we do drought we just don't water them
which is stupid but what will you guys
do a longer time of water deprivation or
just ignore extreme water deprivation
what do you what the plans there you
were looking at Morris yes severe water
deficit so were even less same around a
time yes in another time and when you go
to wash you are you planning on
rejoining it on Ivan's lap it's it's a
possibility and they have to go within
our rotations first yeah yeah I have a
question for you
computational science Alex's time Owens
I got a question for you yep the two
programs that's used to analyze the
differential expression dc2 in the edge
are it's not surprising that they give
different results but it seemed kind of
surprising that it gives such different
results that varied between the two
species one was what he consistent from
one and one was less consistent for the
two what what does that tell you well I
think
it was more the differences was more due
to the the RNA seek data itself then the
the two programs so for we noticed that
for a site area like our first like very
initial call the control step was just
their snip calling on the RNA seek data
sets and the clustering for this may be
you'd expect that the clustering for
snip calling would be pretty tight
because you just yeah calling snips
if one variety has it then it should
have it right but if we were looking at
a scenario data it was just really noisy
you didn't see any clustering at all
which which kind of indicates that or
the data quality was not necessarily the
best this burgum data was we had a lot
more data for the sorghum samples than
stereo samples so that could have been
why so but that kind of raises another
question how do you know that EDR is
giving you the best data we don't yeah
didn't really put any you know final
like I guess decision on which ones test
mainly because we didn't really know
they both ones probably like ec2 seems
to be more sensitive less sensitive than
a jar but we don't really know which
ones been so Dena are two people do sort
of manual checking in different species
to see how well these things work or
they're just programs that are out there
that people use and don't really pay any
attention to that I don't know we didn't
really pay we just basically followed
what other people usually use I mean
they seem seems to be used across
different organisms I would say yes and
yes Tom yeah thanks I think that's I
think it's really important that people
recognize the limitations associated
with the commercial
programs out there to do this type of
analysis yeah retractor atomic analysis
it's it's hard to do controls yeah how
do you know yeah I have a question this
is Tim seller here it's actually related
to Michael's earlier question the the
lack of a very strong effect on your
transcriptomics by the drug treatment I
went I'm wondering if your
high-throughput phenotyping data showed
evidence of decreased transpiration
rates due to snow model closing and also
decreased growth height growth or a
number of leaves that kind of thing I
personally don't really know there is
something else there's a postdoc that
was doing the analysis on the mission
houses and there was something I think
is like decreased leaf area for the
dress dress plants are compared to
compared to non-cash missed plants so
well those two things the Wobble closure
and decreased expansion growth are
usually very sensitive to small
decreases in water status so those would
be interesting to look at with the high
throughput phenotyping data the other
thing is I wasn't clear did you sample
the entire seedling or only the mature
leaf portion it is only the pitcher
leaves okay so not the expanding tissue
at all
all right that's important to know good
excellent presentation thank you thank
you I have one more question is not a
picture of you in the back wall there at
an earlier age hey that's my brother
actually okay I maybe it's a freshman
photo sorry
great job okay nice job Alex cool thank
you my next talk will be from Clara
Morrow her concentration in sustainable
plant production and after graduation
she hopes to continue to explore her
love of plants and the natural world by
pursuing a career in agricultural
extension the Tyler Bradt talk today is
tarping for weed management and reduced
tillage systems Claire all right hello
everybody can you can't hear me okay yes
all right well when we just start by
saying that I hope everybody is healthy
and in a place where they feel safe
today I'm gonna talk to you about the
work I did at the core know small farms
program more specifically tarping for
weed management reduced tillage systems
so this was done in the Cornell small
farms reduced tillage project that's a
multi-year project I believe it's in its
ninth year right now oh and that's
important because when you adopt reduced
tillage system you tend to see a yield
gap at the beginning while the system
adjusts this was also an organic system
and it's particularly hard for organic
farmers to adopt reduce tillage just
because they tend to use it as a method
of weed control since they don't have
access to herbicides so this project
collects data on labor yield temperature
week counts pretty much anything you can
think of just so that we can really
create a full picture for farmers of
what it means to adopt a reduced tillage
system so when we talk about tarping
we're not talking about these typical
blue tarps that you're probably used to
we're talking about these much larger
black plastic tarps that are much
thicker and require several people to
move and you apply those two to four
weeks before planting and after harvest
in some cases they're even overwintered
on beds and what they do is they block
out the light and they heat up hopefully
kill you
for any weeds and creating sort of a
stale seed bed effect so here I have a
little video of us removing some tarps
you can see it takes a couple people to
move and we're revealing some nice
beautiful beds there to plant into that
was actually not a very fun day on the
farm we had some geese come through and
those charts were absolutely covered in
coop and not very
so I figured the easiest way to show our
experimental design was just to show it
to you so here we have our player to the
acreage and this was done at the
Thompson research farm over three Bell
and we have a randomized block setup
here with our four blocks and so within
each row we have a tillage treatment
there's a no-till a shallow toe and a
deep tail treatment and then within each
row we have our compost I mean a mulch
combination so the gray represents
compost the white is nothing and the
yellow is strong so then within each
tillage we also have tarps here so
there'd be a tarp on a no-till treatment
a tarp on a shallow tail treatment and a
tarp on a deep tail treatment here so we
have pretty much every combination of
tarp tillage and mulch so these are
results looking at weep counts halfway
through the season and you can see
already that our tarp treatments have
much lower wheat counts than are not
intolerant to treatment which is exactly
what we would be hoping to see and here
are our results of wheat biomass right
before harvest and you can see already
that our tarp treatments have a much
much lower we biomass than ourn on tire
treatment which is exactly what we would
be don't think I see so just to show how
this also reflected yield I have circled
the tarps treatments and red just to
make it a little bit easier for you for
you to see and they're right next to
their counterparts here and you can see
that in pretty much every category our
tarp treatments kind of have much higher
or not much higher in some cases but
have higher yield than our non top
treatments but where you can really see
the difference in the field it's very
exciting
so here are two comparable systems these
are both no-till compost and you can see
our tarp lettuce bed here is just
absolutely beautiful
and our non car corn was absolutely
covered in cheap weed and all of these
things so I would just like to
acknowledge Ryan Mayer who is the
project lead and was
very fun to work with over the summer
and the program did a director Onew Rama
Rajyam and I had a wonderful summer
there at the small farmers program are
there any questions
great job
any questions from the crowd it Claire
this is Tony I was wondering if you
think using tarp um it seems like it's
it's limited to maybe smaller farm
operations can you see this kind of
expanding to to larger operations are
you limited by B just having you know
the size of the time what are your
thoughts oh it definitely that is a
limiting factor um just because it's so
labor-intensive to add and remove the
tarps and as you make the tarps bigger
it becomes even more labor-intensive you
can get larger tarps um in terms of if a
larger farm could adopt it I feel like
this really does have some potential if
they're willing to put any labor effort
required just because of how we saw you
know such fewer weeds so then it also
reduces you know wheat cultivation time
that we'd have to do you know during the
season and stuff um it is it was a lot
of labor and it was hard so it is
limiting but you know I think it has
potential just because we got such great
data you know that was really good
results right thanks Claire now that was
great thanks for the presentation Claire
are those tarps reusable and so like how
many times could they be reused yeah
they are reusable some of them are a
little beat up but we've had tarps that
have lasted the entire project pretty
much which is cool to see and that's 9
or 10 years which is great but yeah as
long as you they're stored properly and
you're careful when you're taking them
on and off you can reduce them which is
great to see which is a lot better than
the black plastic you typically see on
an organic farm that just gets thrown
away yeah ok thank you
hi Claire this is Neil I was just
curious how long the carryover effects
of the tarp might last so you know one
could envision maybe the first month or
two you have really good control but by
the end of the growing season maybe
there would be less control yeah exactly
and that is kind of what we saw was that
you know over the course of the growing
season there were a lot more annual
weeds popping up but this did do a great
job controlling our perennial weeds and
I guess what it was mainly used for was
to just get a we got a really good jump
on the weeds instead of at the very
beginning of our season having to deal
with it we had some time where plants
were getting established and they were
really free of them and it does it does
the effects tend to you know diminish
over time but it gave us a really good
jump on the weeds and you can see it
reflected in the yields to our tarps
really were helping our plants grow and
get established well which was nice to
see Clara their data on talking in
multiple years so if you tarp the same
field one year the second year the third
year do you see a reduction in weed
populations the weed pressure over time
yeah so I just I gave you data on the
year that I worked when we did the
lettuce crop but this data does look a
lot better than the first year that they
did tarps and over time yet it does get
less and less over year over the years
with the reduced tillage system which is
really cool to see there's a question
from John forest it says where the top
sorry sorry where the tarps reused yep
these were just rolled up and stored by
us after they were removed and then put
back on my yes afterwards
great thanks for that question John
other questions for Claire um what did
you guys do with the harvest okay well
we donated what we could to the southern
tier Food Bank and we also had
he'll take someone fits nice so maybe if
you had a Dolman he'll see si you have
to have a little bit of our lettuce
unfortunately um a lot of it just the
field heat as we were harvesting got a
lot of lettuce looking you know
silvery um but we donated what we could
and we had a whole big box truck be
taken but unfortunately a lot of it had
to be composted which was not focusing
okay great job okay next up we have
Peter J Oppenheimer and Peter is a Plant
Pathology concentrator he's also got a
second major in environmental and
sustainable science and sustainability
Sciences after graduation Peter will
pursue a PhD in Plant Pathology at North
Carolina State University then he's
gonna study
kesariya mycotoxins in wheat and today
his title is using mass spectrometry to
analyze the host response in nicosia
Nepenthe AMA with Demi AMA - in
superinfection by 2 M related viruses
hopefully he will explain that better
than I just announced it thank you Mike
can everybody hear me and see my screen
ok yep yeah awesome
yeah thank you for everyone thank you
everyone for being here today I'll be
talking about the research I conducted
last summer at the National University
of Singapore where I used mass
spectrometry to analyze the host
response in tobacco it's a super
infection by two unrelated viruses so
the phenomenon that we were studying in
our research is called heterologous
super infection exclusion is analogous
in some way to a vaccine for plants
except of course the mechanism works
very differently so super infection
exclusion is the ability of an already
established virus and plants to prevent
the subsequent reinfection of another
virus and when these two viruses are
distantly or unrelated viruses is known
as heterologous super infection
exclusion or HSE
and in our experimental system our two
viruses our two viruses are T and B 43 a
and cucumber mosaic virus tmv 43 a is a
mutated virus of team B which replicates
much slower slower and also produces few
too little symptoms in the plants and is
protecting infection from CMV which is a
very more virulent virus it causes
symptoms of severe mosaic and systemic
necrosis and has the widest known host
range of any plant virus and so the
question that we're asked that we're
asking our research is how the super
infection with this mutant strain virus
effect the CMV viral accumulation in
tobacco and we predict that viruses that
are super infected will see a decrease
in CMV accumulation here is our
experimental design as you see groups
number four and number five are our
super infected plants and we also have
plants that are singly infected CMV and
Team B 43 a and we are collecting RNA
and protein samples on days 4 10 and 16
and we are comparing these RNA and
protein samples from our super infected
plants to our singly infected plants so
when we when we extract our RNA we will
use that to amplify the viral coat
protein in the virus to confirm that the
plants were correctly inoculated and
infected with the Craig fires the
proteins will be used for both a Western
blot which will also amplify the COPE
will also show that coat protein but it
will also show us the quality of the
protein itself which is important
because it's important for mass
spectrometry which is what will give us
differentially abundant proteins and so
we can compare the abundance of certain
proteins in our super infected plants to
our the abundance of proteins in our
singly infected plants and from the
differential regulation of these
proteins we can come up with possible
mechanisms of why our cross protected
plants are not seeing fewer CMV slower
seeing the accumulation than singly
infected plants and so our results
showed that CMV accumulation decreased
in super infected plants which is
positive and also showed that proteins
associated with photosynthesis were
significantly up regulated in super
infected plants and proteins associated
with fatty acid synthesis were
significantly decreased in super
affected plants and so we believe this
is significant because CMV often attacks
the photosynthetic pathways in tobacco
and so by increasing regulation of post
and bike pigments in super infected
plants we believe in mitigate some of
the damage done to those systems and
allows the tobacco to have the necessary
energy to defend against the infection
and we also interesting you saw the
decrease in tsveti acid synthesis
related proteins which we believe
inhibits the formation of the VRC viral
replication complex so CMV is a virus
that requires a lipid envelope to be
constructed before entering a new cell
and this viral envelope is composed of
lipids and these lipids it accrues from
the host you know the host is machinery
and if the host down regulates the
synthesis of lipids the virus will be
starved of lipids and will be unable to
form this lipid envelope and thus be
stuck in the cell and will replicate
much slower and so the implications of
this study are wide ranging because to
our knowledge this is the very first
report indicating that a virus is
complete is able to exclude infection by
a completely unrelated virus
and this report can go a long way to
inform future research of the possible
mechanisms behind HSE and maybe one day
you will be able to create maybe use
this for biotechnology to create a
protector and preventing
seeing the infections in crops I would
like to thank the members of my lab at
the National University of Singapore
Prem young mercy and dr. settlin Wong
for being very gracious towards me and
teaching me all the necessary lab
protocol and for my research and I also
like to thank the cow school Fellows
Program for providing me of this
opportunity and help me become a costume
accustomed to life abroad insane poor
thank you and it's anybody have any
questions I can add some now thank you
good job questions for Peter
here that was a really exciting piece of
research do you know does the mutated
tobacco mosaic virus provide some
resistance to the wild type of tobacco
so this experiment was preceded by
another experiment in the same lab where
they used wild-type tmv as the
Challenger virus and also found that tmv
43a
was able to cause a decrease in T and V
viral load and through and I forget the
mechanism behind I had to do with our OS
species accumulation very exciting yeah
this was work in a plant beyond Vincent
methane Jana
I might have worked in a plant behind
but yeah with this system have they
tried it in tomato or or in a queue
Kermit I don't know I don't know if
they've tried in in other plants I'm
sorry I can't answer that question I
know that the other the other
experiments with the TMV 43a was also
done using the same host and I don't I
think I think I also remember seeing
research where they created this mutant
strain virus and in a different
experiment and I think I remember that
being done to back up to I'm not
entirely sure thank you a good question
though cool thanks I've seen nothing 9
chat ok great job Peter thank you next
up we have Cassandra Proctor and
Cassandra is a concentrator in plant
molecular and developmental biology the
physiology concentration her plans are
to take a gap year before entering
graduate school and the title of today's
talk is investigating the role of
replication factor C or R FC during our
busk euler mycorrhizal symbiosis so as
Mike said I'm gonna be giving my
talk on the project that I've been
working on for my honors thesis in the
Harrison lab title investigating the
role of replication factors see genes
during the Oscar my cries of symbiosis
my screen is blocked on my face anyway
as an introduction so the I rescue my
cries the symbiosis is an endosymbiotic
association between a family of fungi
and the roots of many land plants and in
in exchange for different mineral
nutrients that the fungus provides the
plant the plant provides the fungus with
a carbon source so what happens is the
fungal spores like Burma in the soil
until a plant root grows close to where
the spore will start producing these
hyphy that will grow either out into the
soil or torch the plant room where the
once they reach the plant root they form
this specialized structure called the
hypogeum which allows the high feet and
at rate the epidermal cells and grow
into the inner cortical cells where they
form these highly branched structures
called Arbus fuels and this is where
this is this type of nutrient exchange
between the fungus and the plant and
interestingly this symbiosis is very
ancient and it's highly conserved in
plant species it's believed to only have
evolved once in the first land plant and
plant species nowadays that can't form
the symbiosis have lost that ability
over time so based on this highly
conserved ability of pilot genomics
study was done that compared the genomes
of 50 different plant species 11 of
which had lost their ability of form the
symbiosis and the idea was that you
could get a list of genes that were
hypothesized to be conserved for the am
symbiosis because genes that were only
found in the am capable species probably
and not those species that were unable
to fund the symbiosis
were probably conserved because of their
ability to function in the symbiosis in
this study yielded around over a hundred
orthologs in the model species minute
coverage from Kerala which is a species
that's been used in this study and two
of these genes found
cago are annotated as replication factor
C genes between named RFC a and RFC B
and interestingly in this tree with
other RFC proteins you can see there's
five different plant species and a rabid
abscess is the only one in this tree
that has lost their ability to form the
symbiosis and in the RFC a in RFC be
cleared you see a rabid abscess is
missing the more about the replication
factor C complex this complex is
essential for DNA replication and repair
in all eukaryotes and what happens is
the subunits come together to form the
complex in they bind PCNA or the
proliferating cell nuclear antigen which
is a clamp flirting protein and so when
the subunits find the key cma
they open and close it around the DNA it
release it and then the pc and i can
recruit the polymerase is needed for DNA
replication to occur and all this
complex like I said is essential for all
eukaryotes the arrangement of the
subunits is varies across species and
it's not known in medical term patch
Allah moving on to the main objective of
this project it was to functionally
characterize RFC a and IRC B genes
during our bus killer Mike Raisa
symbiosis by first determining the
spatial expression patterns of the genes
second studying the a.m. phenotype of a
double meeting and three analyzing the
structure and sequence of our the
proteins are FC a in RC B to identify
potential functions so going to the
first objective promoter Gus constructs
for RFC a and RC B we're transiently
transformed into the routes medicago
drug bachelor um and as you can see here
in blue is shown the Gus expression in
green you see the WGA expression which
is a fluorescent protein that stains
fungal lost animals this green here will
show where the fungus is in the cell and
for both RFC a and RFC B you can see the
bus and the WGA overlap in the merged
images which means
these proteins are being expressed in
cells that contain the fungus so cells
containing Arbus kills just interesting
because this supports what was found in
the file of genomic study that these
genes are most likely conserved because
they function in the symbiosis and
because they're found themselves
participating in the symbiosis you can
see that that the ports of the
hypothesis moving on to the second
objective of the project by studying the
a.m. phenotype so in the Defiler
genomics study i in 2016 it was also
published at an RFC B Newton showed an
overall reduction in route length
colonization at five weeks whose
planting and the real length
colonization is just the overall amount
of internal hyphy in the route however
when I looked at the double meatman
there was no change in length
colonization found a visual analysis of
the potential visual analysis of the
Arbus cules actually showed that there
might be a potential mutant phenotype
because as you can see in the wild-type
your Rusk you look very healthy they
appear to fail most of the cell or
highly branched wears then the double
mutant you see some almost wild-type
looking or bus kills you also see a lot
more that just don't peer to be as
healthy or degenerative so when this was
analyzed actually there was significant
decreases found in both the our bus
queue area and the proportion of the
cell film by the hospital for the W in
both the three weeks and the five week
crews planting samples so then moving on
to the final objective a gene sequence
and structure analysis of RFC a and RFC
P showed that they might spur different
functions so what happened was as you
can see here all of the are RF CAS have
this concern and RFC proteins habits
concerned
RFC domain which is the reason the RFC a
an RF cv were annotated as replication
factors but in addition to these
domains both our SCA and our CB had
these unknown domains that are about the
same size at the RFC doing the idea here
was a blast search was done with this
the amino acid sequence of the unknown
domains to see if any sort of hits would
give us an idea of where these domains
might have come from however though
clearly the results of the blast search
after they were aligned and neither the
tree only produced other AM specific RFC
genes and interestingly the RF CA
results only showed other RF CA proteins
in other species and RFC be only yielded
RFC B results in other species which
guess the idea that these mode domains
might not be homologous moving on some
discussion points on first as I
mentioned before the gene expression
data really supports the hypothesis from
the 2016 file of genomic study that the
RFC's were conserved you do their
function during the symbiosis
additionally the compromised Arbus skill
development in the double mutant
suggests that what both of the genes are
necessary for the healthy symbiosis and
a single mutant single mutants are
really need to be analyzed to look at
our vascular development to see whether
it's both of the genes causing this
compromised development or if it's just
one finally are the different unknown
domains and the genes may suggest that
the two have different functions which
again highlights the need to analyze the
single mutant plants to determine really
if they do play a similar function or if
they're doing two different things
during the symbiosis finally I'd like to
acknowledge my GI doctor Maria Harrison
and my postdoc mentor dr. Ayman Bravo
for all the help and the opportunity
that they gave me during this project as
well as the rest of the Harrison lab for
just the friendship and the mentorship
that they've offered me for the past
five years that I've interned and worked
in the lab and I finally like to
acknowledges that this project was
funded by the Americans
a plant biologist summer undergraduate
research fellowship and the NSF plant
genome research grant thank you and does
anyone have any questions
nice job Cassie I got a question related
to the those domains on the on the two
proteins that she said only mapped to a
a genes or beatings if you looked any
more the structure of those genes I mean
you can do a lot of structural analysis
on the sequences that should tell you
are there similar domains are there
different structural domains even though
they may not match up to other things we
looked at that oh I've tried different
types of blast search yes I blast search
that went back him back to see if there
was anything that could come up is
anything other than the replication
factor I've also looked used some
different programs that try to figure
out different structural parts of the
domains like looking for nuclear
localization signals and all sorts of
other stuff and it really wasn't able to
find anything conclusive so as of right
now I do not know where these domains
are coming from and I don't have an
ideal but there is evidence that either
they come from two different places and
they're not homologous or they just
diverge so long ago that you can't find
similar and he needed to find the
homology criteria thank you okay
beautiful job thank you Cassie
okay our next presentation is from
Benjamin rouse my Benjamin designed his
own concentration in physiology and
ecology of crop plants after graduation
he will enter industry while
establishing a farmstead reading program
for colored raspberry and Blackberry
today's talk is understanding how
inherent noise measurements place limits
on high-throughput phenotype for those
of you who do and do not know me my name
is
Benjamin rouse and Tom Owens help mentor
me through this research of
understanding how inherent noise
measurements place limits on
high-throughput phenotyping so going
over a little bit the roadmap the talk
here Hydra phenotype measurements are
based on the direct relationship between
fluorescence and synthesis and we're
going to talk about some terms that help
that you'd be defined in relation to
fluorescence and they will help us
derive a light induction curve and then
we help us understand the instrument
noise contribution and then our strategy
to overcome this problem will then be
shown so a little background information
here's a picture of what we know as
light energy will enter a plant and
there are competing processes against
for this energy within the plant against
electron transport found in
photosynthesis and fluorescence is one
of those competing process the Ruston's
can simply be fine as a readmission with
folk tom our picture here shows
chlorophyll dissolve and alcohol under
white light and it's fluorescent green
as opposed to it did still be dissolved
in our alcohol but UV light show that is
red so these fo and FM signals here will
be read by the high-throughput
thermometer
excuse me and since we know that
fluorescence in photosynthesis are
directly related
under getting an accurate measurement of
the fluorescence signal is important or
to getting accurate flows into the
phenotype so these signals read by the
machine are understood as light
induction curves and at a time even
going through a like Generic my
induction curve would be impossible but
i would like to introduce the fact of
the chemistry and physics gets much more
interesting really quickly big takeaway
from the sli's that all the measurements
associated with a photosynthetic rate
are based are scaled the dark-adapted FO
value
simplify things a bit we're going to
start with by darker Daphney example
when take a sample when i put it to a
dark room and by doing this allows the
floor film to have a maximum capacity to
you this light energy driving electron
transport we apply a modulating light to
our sample it's a very low light
intensity that does induce some
fluorescence but it doesn't change the
samples photosynthetic physiology put
another way with the modulated light on
the sample remains dark-adapted
and because we know the capacities
reverse in vista photosynthesis in a
dark adapted sample is maximum the
fluorescence level is minimal with
or call this level fo to reveal the
other extreme of photosynthesis we need
to expose the sample to a short pulse of
light that saturates photosynthesis
therefore we call the maximum level
fluorescence FM although the absolute
amount of fluorescence from any leaf is
highly variable the ratio of FM over fo
is highly conserved at about four point
nine - for this reason the values of fo
and FM are used to normalize all
fluorescence measurements so that those
measurements going to use to make
comparison between leaves or treatments
consider the time scale that we're
concerned with the noise is not a
biological origin the noise is due to
the instrument in fact noise is present
in all instruments at some level the
contribution of the biology with this
problem is the variation in FO between
different samples meaning many different
fos if the noise level is due to the
instrument a biology causes fo to vary
between samples and the signal-to-noise
ratio gets smaller as a level of FO
fluorescence gets smaller what this
means is that when FL levels are low
such as below zero values determine the
actual value of fo is not possible and
the Deb from that sample cannot be used
our fo right helps us show the variation
of FO during high-throughput application
the F intensity very clearly increases
in the upper right hand corner direction
here remember now fo is used to
normalize all these subsequent and light
adapted measurements for synthetic
genotyping the experimental design is
then to make fo artificially smaller by
doing so it allows us to see when the
error occurs to do this we look at three
different maize samples with at least
three different areas of interest the
picture seen here is one of the maize
leaves and each with six different areas
of interest each with a different FO
value now so the new pencil faith was
replaced between a sample and the
detector and should we know that the
neutral density filters only change the
intensity of the fluorescence signal
perceived by the Flom etre and not the
light conditions that luminate the
sample establish its its physiology thus
we're able to isolate noise bound
machine so we understand that that
inherent instrument noise can contribute
to the high throughput measurements of
photosynthesis we know that they arrived
as a consequence
the natural variability in
epifluorescence levels of believes and
we know the samples with ethical values
that are low compared to the average fo
levels in an array cannot be measured
there are two possible ways to overcome
this sorting samples by fo levels before
measurements which diminishes the
inherent high throughput character or
get manufactured to modify a code to
allow greater averages for fo and FS
measurements since there's a state
conditions lastly and so not leastly I
wanted to not only just personally
acknowledge dr. Tom Owens but I wanted
to extend my deepest respect for his
integrity and care that you shown
working in this project as instruction
guidance and patience continual teach me
the rest of my life and thanks doc so
I'll be happy to take your questions
questions
tom is smiling big that's what we're
supposed to do right yeah no questions
okay here we have Raul Campos azama and
his concentration is in plants and human
health and his title is grandma's
potions discussions on herbal remedies
and cultural identity among Latin X
individuals okay so hi everyone my name
is Raul and today I'm gonna discuss um a
research that I did in the fall of 2019
so I'm really interested in ethnobotany
and more importantly in the ethnography
because I've always felt like that part
has been kinda not discussed in like as
no pharmacological or botanical research
it actually led to some pretty vile
things you know like like um like um
biopiracy and and things like that
additionally I'm interested in the way
that some medicine and migration kind of
interact with with each other um and in
the summer 2019 I had the opportunity to
do an independent research project where
I arrived to this research question
right um so how does Adam Medicine
influence the culture identity among
college-aged line-x immigrants right um
so basically what they did I interviewed
people and ask them about their use of
ethno medicine and how that interacts
with their culture identity
um so because it was a quick pilot study
I had no official hypotheses but I did
have my opinions inform by the
literature so this is basically righted
right the study lasted about three
months I interviewed a total of 47
people in both English Spanish and some
Mayans and methods that are used was
ethnography with a informal
semi-structured interviews I gather at
the botanical data and ethnographic data
which I'll show you that mechanical data
right here um and as you can see I'm
with the ethnobotanical data um you have
everything from family starting with
then you have specimen of the popular in
the parts used of preparations the
applications the percent cited on the
elements it cures for and the
pharmacological activities too though at
the rightmost side and yeah um so how
does all of this lead back to my
question right um how does after
medicine influence culture identity I'm
oncology line-x immigrants right um in
my nog Rafi I learned some essential
things right and that is that the use of
Ethne medicine can help to deal with
trauma of migration and other downstream
social effects like racism and
xenophobia and mine you lose all a pilot
study so this is something that needs to
be liked for further addressed in
research but essentially in my
ethnography I was able to find these
patterns um and I'm about to show you
but I also want to know that I'm
shortening this a lot because of time
but these things are much more nuanced
than they appear
um so we have something like migration
and cultural identity which are things
that can actually affect people's
self-esteem and self value
additionally identity is highly mutable
especially in the light of migration it
is affected by social positioning more
than we like to accept another thing is
that when people
marginalized communities migrated to a
country that's hostile towards them they
experienced something called cultural
bereavement which meaning people mourn
the loss of their culture and this
usually comes from the from the pressure
of a forced assimilation which can lead
to a variety of mood disorders like
anxiety depression and in fact migrant
population of the highest indexes of
untreated mental health issues um
there's something that can help with
these issues this idea of performing
culture or like feeling one is connected
to two other roots and things like that
and particularly what helps is food and
religiosity and something is at the apex
of food and religiosity is ethno
medicine so according to many studies
performing these parts of culture can
help with um can help with the effects
of a culture ation and more successfully
integrate immigrant societies into the
the Kliq room into the into the current
culture there's also a very interesting
thing about asthma medicine I used to
it's like a mystical component it's very
unique to to to the culture that it
comes from um this ultimately connects
people with their loved ones
and and it makes much more sense in the
light of ethno medicine of why certain
certain like clinical perceptions of
ethno medicine is perceived as opposed
to Western biomed medicine so what why
is all this important right so it uh so
in a more conceptual like big picture
thing is that 80% of the world uses
herbal medicine as primary health care
and this is crucial to addressing global
health issues and and so forth but
things like this can also help with
pharmacological research through various
inverse methods of pharmacology finally
it's very important to detail the
clinical experiences of marginalized
communities to provide a more inclusive
and more competent care so I I want to
give a talk to
the Cornell McNair Scholars program who
really helped me out and have always
been like such a pillar of strength and
hope for me and to my mentors Julia
frieszo and Rachel Dudley and if you
have any questions please let me know
thank you so much questions yeah
well this is Neil very nice job
I was curious in the interviews
how do people address so so taking
herbal medicine in the context of not
being you know in their culture with
their family members so so would they
would they still glean benefit but was
it not as much benefit because they
weren't there with their grandma or
family members so kind of more related
to that context so what I saw in my snog
Rafi is that a lot of the parts when
people mentioned that they were using as
nomads it was because they were like it
usually comes from somewhere that's like
like one of the main things about no
medicine it's passed down like I
intergenerationally right so um people a
lot of people are saying that like it
was less effective because whose
something they'd were have two who
hadn't minister themselves and a lot of
parts also in the literature as no
medicine is um it seems to be much more
like effective when it's administered by
like a community member or someone that
is perceived to be very knowledgeable in
these in in in this which is really
interesting yeah but there's actually
some studies that like show like the
form of the increased pharmacological
activity or placebo activity of certain
like like ethno medicinal treatments as
opposed to like controls and stuff like
that yeah thank you that's great yeah
that really addresses my question
did you enjoy enjoy doing all the
interviews rule oh my god yeah so it was
essentially everyone like it was
a lot of these people were my friends I
did have to discard some some interviews
because of that but it was everyone from
like my community here at Cornell so it
was like a very like personal project
for me yeah alright yeah ok thanks Raul
our next talk is from Samuel Steinbach
and Samuel is a concentrator in soil
science his talk today is the effects of
herbicide on loblolly silviculture ok
hello everyone my name is Samuel Stern
Beck and over the previous summer I
worked at North Carolina State
University for the soil science area and
there I worked with Rachel Cooke who is
a professor of silviculture so civil
culture is the processing of trees for
lumber or coke word specifically I was
focusing on loblolly pines which as you
can see relatively tall trees and the
pine cones we say are about the size of
a potato Tator finest AIDA
easy way to remember it so some come in
the southeastern United States
particularly North Carolina which is
where we were and then the two most
common ways to prevent weeds from
popping up in this system is using the
mass appear or sofa meter on and as
appear is used for herbaceous speeds
also Flemish Iran is used for woody
brushes the problem is that in
silvicultural systems there's usually
it's very hard to get the
to get we'd cover reduce because s is a
pine forest there's not much time
between seasons where you can spray it
down just to the air as you can see the
two main ways are the helicopter
overhead flying or just going in
manually and spraying but as I said is
it's a pine system you can't spray it
after it has the canopy cover and then
the manual walking around is
labor-intensive so in this experiment
we're trying to figure out what is
another way to reduce the cover of of
woody and herbaceous weeds so the first
way we were thinking is the hardwood
release system which is spraying the
herbicides after the trees are
established and planted and then the
other method was the site preparation
method which is spraying the ground and
covered before the trees are planted and
then after the trees are planted and
then just a side note was that the soil
that we were looking at was a Little Joe
series which was fine mix active but the
most important part was that is a well
draining soil
so the purpose of this as I said was to
quantify the relationship between the
densities of the hardwood pines and then
the weeds and then to also determine the
effects of the different timing to see
which one was more effective and if
either them had a larger benefit so to
quantify how
affective each system was we check the
heights of the trees the live crown
species species covering and also the
DBH DBH was measured using the state you
can see on the bottom which was a
specifically a DBH tape and you would
wrap it around the tree and that would
give you the diameter recite and then on
the in phenomena used you step to a
specific distance from the tree and you
would measure it from the bottom to the
top and that would give you the height
so these are the results on the left you
can see the untreated where there is no
spraying and you can see that it's very
covered in it so even hard to see
through the
to the undergrowth to the pines on the
site release was slightly better but you
can still see there you can see the pine
trees but there's still some cover
compared to the site prep where there's
barely any cover and for the most part
there's all pine trees so this was the
actual quantitative data for the
untreated and the site prep there was
the greatest significant difference but
compared to untreated into your release
there is not a significant difference so
we can say that there was a significant
difference between untreated site prep
which was when there was the spraying of
the herbicides before the trees were
planted and then you can see that there
is a slightly significant association
between the pine basal area and the
hardwood basal area so there is the
improvement and the need to continue
working on decreasing the hardwood and
increasing the pine dizzle area so I'd
like to thank everyone at North Carolina
State University that helped with this
project Rachel Cooke and her lab
technician manager
Morgan Schultz's along with Jerry
Creighton who was person in charge of
the forest that we were using for the
experiments and then also North Carolina
State University and DRA you thank you
and I'd be happy to answer any questions
good job Samuel ice and this is Marvin I
can understand that
need to have sort of these monocultures
of pine trees there for wood production
but has there been any thought about
increasing the diversity at least after
establishment to may be mitigate some of
the pest problems that might occur
heavily monoculture system
um yes there is however it's at this
point still most effective to even to go
with the monoculture is just because of
the mass production and the amount of
bulk wood that you're able to pull in
because it's only over a 20 year period
that you need to keep it safe for that
you could just after the 20 years plough
it over and plants a different
monoculture so for
Ashley monoculture seems to be the way
to go for now yeah one of the things
that I found impressive about this was
that it was a 20-year experiment
that's some serious forethought okay
great job Samuel thank you
our next our next talk is from David
John his concentration is plant
pathology implant microbiology and his
talk today is entitled developmental
changes of carbohydrates in peach blush
thank you Mike
kay hermie okay thanks and hello
everyone I'm David and today I'd like to
introduce you my experimental learning
project developmental changes of
carbohydrates in each flash in this
winter break I worked in dr. Lyle on
chance lab and the first question here
is why are we doing this why we test
hits the carbohydrate level in peach
there are two reasons the first one is
carbon hydrolyzed is directly related
food quality and flavor and another
reason is we want to based on this
project to find out the developmental
regulation of synthesis of secondary
metabolites and here's the materials 147
samples were collected there from six
calibers there should have seven but
actually one caliber were impacted by
black rose which is a story and to show
the developmental changes we collect
them in nine dates and the ten span as
three months from April to August in
each group we have three or five
repetitions on the right you can see
there are some colorful pictures and
each color actually represents one
cultivar here's a larger picture you can
as you can see oh sorry
as you can
here this role represents the quality
cultivars and this is the collection
date and here's a dry weight and some
days like that all samples were
processed in to the freeze-dried sponder
because they are much easier to handle
waste the first step of my experiment is
the extraction we put this Condor we add
methanol and ripto into this ponder and
centrifuge a few times a few times and
the a little bit ponder on the bottom of
this val is sugar sugar as it's got the
carbon hydrates we need and the next
step is the deviation the chemical
formula looks very complex and but the
main point here is we want to make the
polar
Blacker's like sugar sugar i say it's
more volatile we want some the more
volatile because the next step is the
GCMs from the name you can tell that
this technology is the combination
between the gas chromatography and mass
spectrometry the advantage of GCS is
really good at separating different
compounds from a mixture and the mass
spectrometry can accurately detect
what's the molecular is so in this
project
the sample was injected here and went
into this column they are separated here
and the detector with her asked the
concentration and the water molecular is
in the right you can see a GC n X
machine in dr. Chan's lab it was working
at the time Ethel picture the whole
project were still unfinished and so I'm
so sorry that I cannot present some
conclusions or takeaways but here is
that rotate have run the GCMs it is
based on one sample here you can see
many in pigs
and each pigs with represent one
compound the biggest tallest one is
Syracuse in the middle the here's the
Manos like
rattles like glucose and this
small one is the repto which is our
inner control so another things I want
to mention in this presentation is about
lab safety maybe you may you may mention
that you may notice that in the first
step extraction we use the chloroform as
our nonpolar solvent and the chloroform
is very corrosive even at just a few
drops of chloroform can make this
classic form place very ugly and
unfortunately I got a few jobs on my
hands and even I was wearing a pair of
cloth my my hands were turn into like
that it was very itchy and painful and
this luckily this strange feeling went
away a few days later so always be
careful in a lab no matter how familiar
you are with the whole experiment and I
want to thanks dr. chen who helped me a
lot in this project thank you for
listening and in questions or comments
david for david our folks in dr. Chang's
lab continuing these experiments David
oh yes dr. Shah and his group are still
working along with the data yeah nice
hopefully they'll let you know what
happens yeah I hope so
ok excellent job thank you very much
our next presentation is from Daniel
santander Daniel is a computational
biology concentrator and let's
congratulate him we just heard recently
he got a job as a R&D data specialist at
Syngenta which is in his home state of
North Carolina
so congratulations talk today is
computer modeling for greenhouses cool
so thank you so much like dr. Scanlan
said I'm gonna be presenting today about
computer modeling for greenhouses this
is my honors thesis and I got the
opportunity to work on it with dr.
Mattson and one of his former postdocs
in his lab who is dr. Cayle Harvick and
so it was a really cool project to get
to work on with the two of them sort of
the big idea of it is in a traditional
greenhouse you have obviously
supplemental Lightning home but
sometimes it's hung at arbitrary heights
and distances and things so in this
image you can sort of see these are
supposed to be rows of crops in a
greenhouse and you generally have like
this hot spot in the junk in the middle
of the greenhouse and some of the cooler
spots on the outside of the greenhouse
and so these are areas of like low
illuminance and whereas the center of it
will be very high illuminance and so
this is generally a problem just because
as you can see the plants on the outside
are getting less light whereas the ones
on the middle of the greenhouse might be
getting too much light and so the idea
of the project was sort of just to
optimize it and make it as uniform as
possible so you go from this traditional
lighting plan over to this optimize a
lighting plan where the idea is just to
have all the plants in the greenhouse
getting the same amount of light and so
if you were gonna listen to my
presentation you could stop there and
that's just sort of the big idea
but what is the motivations for this so
like I said supplemental lighting can
create hotspots in the greenhouse and
this is really a problem in greenhouse
research it biases the research and
sometimes and you have to like move
around your plants to make sure you
don't have an extra variable in there
and it can also result in variable
yields where for instance the plants in
the middle of the greenhouse might
produce more fruit and like the larger
things like that and the ones on the
outside of the greenhouse might have
lower yield
and so the motivation for this was was
that in order to get more more
consistent yield more consistent data
throughout the greenhouse but also we
wanted to work on it with a computer
program because it is really tedious to
do something like this by hand and so
the computer program that we wanted to
develop with something that could take
in the type of light that you're using
in a greenhouse the size of the
greenhouse and the crop that you're
growing and it would return the optimal
location and hang your supplemental
lights and so what does this work look
like in the real world I apologize I
know these images are a little hard to
look at but the big thing to take away
from these is that in a traditional
lighting plan you normally just hang
your lights in a row
they're arbitrarily hung at the same
height and at the same distance and you
might come in with a light meter but
generally it's just sort of behind it
right above the plans and that's the
intuitive answer but in the other image
you can see in an optimized lighting
plan you can have lights at different
heights lights a variable distances Sun
lights can be turned in different
directions and so this would be
something that would optimize the
uniformity of it and yeah so how do we
go about developing a model to do this
so it started with Gonia photometric
data gonio photometric data it measures
the light at different angles measures
of the light intensity at different
angles from the light source so gonio
means angle photo means light and then
matric means to measure so it's not ring
the light at all the different angles
from it and so this was useful because
we could develop Gonia photometric data
from any light source so if we wanted to
try different different types of
supplemental lighting that could produce
the same files and load it into a
computer model and also it sort of
created a 360 degree 3d image of light
intensity and so this is where we
started the computer model and so we
built up from this gonio photometric
data we started here and we ended up
with something like this where we could
represent multiple lights in a
greenhouse we could put them in rows we
could put them in different positions
and things like that and so these were
sort of I'm going to a little bit more
depth about how we how we got there from
this data to sort of a full-blown
computer
so it started with loading up the Dhoni
ephedrine on trip data and then
interpolating between the data points so
you can see there's really only about
360 data points in this in the ammonia
photometric file and obviously we want
to know any point so the first step was
to enter a blade between the data points
so that we could sort of estimate the
luminous intensity of any point along
the sphere of an equal distance from the
light source and these units were
reported in Candela which if you're not
familiar it's it's a photopic light
intensity it's not really useful to
growing plants but it's what they
reported the diamond so from there we
moved on from using luminous intensity
to illuminance and this changes the data
from spherical values to Cartesian
values and it allows us to to be able to
calculate the illuminance of any point
in the greenhouse and so obviously we
could we started here with the sphere
and now I arbitrarily sort of chose this
bed in a green house of coins that we
could calculate but you could really
calculate any point it could be an inch
away from the light source it could be
ten miles away from the light source it
could be in the greenhouse or it could
be in a different country and you could
calculate the light and sons are the
luminous intensity and so this changed
our units as well it brought us from
Candela to Lux and this is significant
as we move on to the next step which was
converting to photosynthetically active
radiation like I said we were interested
in growing plants obviously and we
needed units that represented the
spectrum of light that plants use so the
last step was to convert from Lux to
photosynthetic photon flux and then
eventually we were able to start
producing these heat maps of sort where
we could see any point in a greenhouse
how much light is it getting simply from
this one light source and then from
there we wanted to combine different
light sources obviously a big green
house has a lot of lights
and a lot of space so we took this one
light and we wanted to see how they
interact well with different lights and
so you can see in this model I was about
six lights in it and even though it's
there's a hot spot right underneath the
light they do begin to develop an even
bigger one through the middle of the
greenhouses they all interact
and so this was significant as well
because lights are sort of a compilation
of effects and then for there we went
into the computational optimization so
now that we have a model to display any
type of lights I could choose a position
I wanted to hang my lights at or
anything I wanted to go from having this
and then computing my traditional
lighting plan to an optimized lighting
plan so how did I go about optimizing
the light so really what you have to do
is test different combos of lights to
find the one that produces the optimally
or named the green costs and this uses a
lot of different computational
techniques mainly just linear
programming and this is challenging
because it's something called an np-hard
problem and key means that it's
non-deterministic algorithm that's
solved in polynomial time and so this
means that you can have different
results on different runs for the
algorithm but most importantly to know
from that is that it's solved in
polynomial time on this graph to the
right you'll see that polynomial time is
over here in the red and as you increase
your data size the time for computation
increases really poorly so the more data
you use in this computational
optimization and the longer the
computation is additionally a solution
can't be fast and correct at the same
time so there's sort of this trade-off
do I want a really refined correct
answer or do I want to wait a week for
it so this was the challenge of it and
of course this became a real-world
problem as you begin to think about how
to apply the software is as a big as you
begin to optimize larger greenhouses
with more lights it's obviously going to
take a longer time and so my conclusions
my research look to identify the optimum
position to place the lights based on
the crop the type of light and the side
of the greenhouse and future research
would ideally look to optimize for
growing in beds not just the entire
greenhouse so rows of it and as well as
integrate software for for crop
interception models so obviously plants
are dynamic they're constantly growing
they're not just on the base of the
greenhouse you would want to know
is the light changing as they grow and
then additionally integrate climactic
data to know how natural sunlight
affects the uniformity of light in the
greenhouse as well and I'd like to thank
for acknowledge at least dr. Kiehl
Harvick right here with some cool plants
and of course dr. Mountain as well with
some cool plants they really help me out
a lot with the project and I'm forever
in their debt so thank you very much
any questions so Daniel that's a really
cool study but I'm gonna put you on the
spot where the question here why did you
choose to make your light measurements
using units of humans or Lux yeah so I
actually didn't choose to we we got the
data from Intertek which is this company
I think somewhere in upstate New York
and they give us the gonio photometric
data unfortunately I had no idea what it
was before I started working on it and
that was just the unit's they gave me
was in Candela and so it was a really
challenging process is actually the
hardest step for me was to was to
transition from Candela to part it took
me months to figure out the math behind
it really yeah because essentially the
there's a waiting curve that's used for
a as zero intensity at 400 and 700
nanometers yeah it makes it a little bit
difficult to work with for example if
you use different types of lights yeah
of course it's different for every
single light which was why I was
challenging I had to develop now a
second data set for each one yeah
because they're really intuitive
question I think only you dr. Owens
would know and Tom I'll chime in that's
that's kind of the state of the
horticultural lighting industry is that
they're reliant on this data taken for
human lighting and then they have to do
didn't expect a Radiometer measurements
to do lighting source specific equations
yeah yeah Daniel I was curious if you
had more thoughts about you alluded to
this is that a crop canopy grows over
time
so as researchers how should we report
light levels at crop canopy should we
measure those every week or something
and take averages over crop cycles of
course so let me go back to an image and
I'll give you an idea of it so in this
image you can see I sort of have these
calculation points in the bed of the
greenhouse and these are what I use to
optimize but ideally you could sort of
develop this like computer model of what
the plants look like the heights of them
in different things and then optimize
based off of that so it really just come
down to building like an image of the
plant in this three-dimensional
environment and then using these
calculation points off of that it would
be I guess involved like a dynamic
growth model of the plant and then just
putting it into this computer model
that's great thank you and I have to
chime in I don't know of anyone
commercially using this kind of method
to optimize lighting layout in a
greenhouse so this could be a huge thing
both for researchers as well as for
commercial growers especially if you're
in kind of rectangular greenhouses with
lots of perimeter space and in kind of
really massive greenhouses with lots of
central space it may not be as much of
an issue any other questions
beautiful job awesome thank you all so
much thank you
okay our next talk is from Joe Chuang
Joe Qi is a systematics and evolution
concentrator his plans after graduation
are to attend graduate school and
today's talk is environmental effects of
Zambia integra folia lipid morphology hi
everyone my name is Joshua today I'm
going to introduce you to my research
environmental effects of zoom integral
folio leaflet morphology so let's first
of all have an introduction let me
refresh your memory about the Zamir
family so damia is a genus within the
families MEAC
the sister group to the
AC is a psycho desi and they both they
both are resides in the psycho dailies
the order so in case you haven't seen a
demon before I took a picture in the HP
conservatory and it is exactly the
species that I'm studying the Zima
interpret olya so you can have a picture
in mind as a Mia are native to the
Western Hemisphere from Mexico to
Bolivia and Brazil as well as in the
West Indies here as a map of the
distribution of Z Mia there are 17 I
accepted species but different people
have different opinions on that the
colors here are showing the major clays
in the genus Tamia except the blue star
which is the sister group micro-cycles I
put a red circle in the map to show the
populations of the America fully that
I'm studying is mainly distributed in
the Florida current state so before I
dive into the messer and material let me
have a brief explanation of why I'm
studying de Mia and why z major Cavalia
of course it's a project of a postdoc in
the lab but officially the fact the
whole family is amazing or even the
whole order I think maybe we are mostly
in danger species that are mostly
defined by their leaflet characters so
as gymnosperms they don't produce
reproduce often as angiosperms and
Dementor folia is one of the most wild
wildly spread species in the family and
they have good herb airmail records so
we are going to find to look forwards of
correlations between the leaflet
morphology and the local environmental
factors so first for the mature and
method the first data set I have is a
collection of 127 herb MCS information
so on the right you can see an
example of the Herman she's over the
overall looking and at the red corner
you can find a paper label and here is a
close-up of the label you can see the
state species name description of the
location the ComTech collector and date
so what I was doing is in putting the
data into a computer file that's the
first data set I have so the second one
the second data set I will do is to
measure measurements of the parameters
as you can see here the length of the
leaflet the width angles and the lengths
of the internals here I posted several
pictures of the leaflet to show you the
variations amount as within the species
so the third dataset is climate the
local climate of of each of each of each
of each a collection so I will pull that
data sets from this website it's all
about the climate you can see rainfall
and temperature a lot of interesting
things so far the results right now I
have a population distribution map
they're mainly attributed in Florida
County as I said before for the future
work I will take measurements of the
leaflet morphology and use some our
language to combine those datasets and
analyze them for for the final type we
will look for the correlations between
leaflet morphology characters and
environmental characters and if the
answer is yes environmental can have an
impact on the leaflet morphology will
continue to ask affecting the size or
the leaflet but if the answer is no it
is still what their answer we then and
say that okay different morphology is a
great way to define family and was that
would like to acknowledge the people in
the spec lab they are all help him
helping me a lot especially dr. Sheila
salesman who is a guide the mentor of my
project and dr. Chelsea expect the PAF
the lab and also my mentor implies us
here are the references and was that are
there any questions of sex for listening
I could this is Chelsea hi Josh a very
nice job I hope all this going well for
you what what might you thinking with
all the data that you were able to
collect what might you anticipate you
would see as a trend across the the
ecology ecological gradients that exist
in Florida
are there any patterns that you're sort
of anticipating will emerge mm-hmm right
now I have a look at into the climate
but I would guess that if you have more
info like more room for you have a
broader I believe a broader leaflet with
a future that's my gift so you expect
with rainfall so again the city the
drought patterns corresponding with
maybe different aspects of the broad
broadly flat morphology yes great job
Joey thanks for staying up so late yeah
yeah thanks it's good to hear you in
person
unmute your video for a minute so we can
all see you and wave good night judge he
is in China having to use this function
it's good to see looks like him great
job Thanks
our next talk is from zitchen way and
the chin is a plant breeding and
genetics concentrator and after
graduation he will come back to Cornell
and do graduate work in plant biology
the caliber is presentation today is
genetic basis for carotenoids stability
in a roboticist Aliannah yes okay
since mic and higher one teaching today
I'm going to talk about my research at
dr. Lee's lab which is about curtain
instability in your open top Siciliano
seeds first of all I like to introduce
some background knowledge about this
project paranoid group of important
natural pigments including more than 100
members they can be found in animal
plant and fungi
they are very beneficial compounds for
human health
for example answer sunny is great for
reproductive health and pro vitamin a is
related to I house most all carotenoids
can serve as antioxidants and zq also
reduce age-related macular degeneration
Ally all the waiting effort to enhance
carotenoids content in crops has made
many good examples such as cotton rice
and cotton mates turnover and post
harvest storage cost great loss all
continents to solve this problem we
firstly need to know two questions about
keratinized the first one is where
captain aware did carotenoids synthesize
and they are synthesized in plus States
in plant cells as you can see there are
mainly five kites all plus states in
plant cells and the varying carotenoid
content and the ways a statment
street-cam tonight another important
question is the biosynthesis and the
degeneration of a very crucial compound
in carotenoids which is beta counting we
try to enhance the stability of beta
carotene by manipulating fourteens
the first one is psy which is a richly
may step in this past week we
overexpress least jeanne robot opsi
seeds the second one is PCH
which will cause the degeneration of
beta counting and help with turnover
plus we use CRISPR cast nine system to
knock out a stream another two genes are
R and H TGT o r could stabilize psy
protein and HTV T is related in with me
e biosynthesis pathway and HDD toh crash
including has vitamin content and which
is assumed to be effective in helping
with stabilize carotenoid so for the
strategy and master part later I will
introduce the plant materials news
English experiment and we use HPLC
method to detect the carotenoid content
and for the plant materials we used we
have 40 lights of BP group as you can
see each letter represents a
manipulation to our plants so we have 40
lights of BP group and then we add the
operation to overarching and we have
also have 40 lights or PPO group also we
have 40 lights of PPO age group so after
screen for positive transformers and we
finally have 10 lights for each group
and after eight weeks post Hari storage
we have formed the seed germination
results and carotenoid content results
so for the seed germination results as
you can see the blue lights represents a
wild-type plant control so as you can
see here so most of all our people eyes
and some PPO and PPO which lies have
have the same higher seed germination
rates than the wild-type and as there
are some a little bit lower but if we
assume that there are no evident
difference between those lines and well
lies by comparing their data and for the
carotenoid fountains we could see that
kaolinite antennae basically matches our
expectations and look as you can see the
tonight most in the PPO which line and
people lines are second and VP lies a
sir and they're all higher than the a
wild type and as we add operation to our
plant materials and as you can see
there's evident difference between
socialites and it is confer it is it is
it we can conclude that it is helpful to
manipulate these four genes in this
research to enhance its ability of
carotenoids so from the from the results
we could conclude that Fitness of
transform and plant is nearly the same
as a normal out high plants and by
probably manipulating these four genes
we can exactly be enhanced the total
carotenoid content in plant seeds and
carotenoids in transform entities has a
higher stability so I want to say dr.
Lee and dr. kambou soon for helping me
and guiding me through this research and
this research is also supported by a
kernel cows and the robot wholly center
of USD thanks for your attention any
questions and comments I have a question
with regard to the CRISPR treatment that
she did and knock out the enzyme that's
involved in breaking down beta-carotene
in the formation of Santha fills so that
was that team was knocked out throughout
throughout the whole plant this gene
been seized and after selecting for
Transformus and we believe that it is
knocked out in our silikal eyes for the
contents test the reason I'm asking that
is because the xanthophylls that are
downstream from that enzyme are
absolutely critical in a function of
photosynthesis yes well through them in
excess light yeah so that's the reason
why we want to test their state fitness
to see whether we we knock loudly
stingwell fact their fitness but you
said that it didn't affect their fitness
yeah harissa products from the seed
germination test and we could see that
there are very slight difference between
different lies and all of the transgenic
lines were knocked out with bees age so
you're only evaluating seed germination
not plant growth in those in the the
lines where you knocked out that enzyme
yeah so I discussed with my mentors and
we haven't decided which is a better way
to evaluates the grow sweetness so
finally we decide that maybe the state
germination will be a good intact for
indicating whether they are good or not
so and because for the plants we use in
less research so they are growing a
greenhouse and they nearly do not need
to use their finto protection system so
so we defined that the germination rate
is important for farmers for selecting
their seeds so we did the plant state
germination testable related to x
question you didn't notice any chlorotic
effects on these and these were no
mutations and are these gene families
duplicated or are their functions
duplicated in our previous plan we
decided to have some pictures for the
silic in the transgenic plants and the
wild-type plant to see whether there is
a difference in color but due to this
where were so we did not do this test
but according to our previous
observation and there there is some
difference in color between the
transgenic flies and wild type
other questions okay great job hope to
see you soon
yes thank you parla you guys have done
great our last talk before lunch is from
Matthews Arizona wits
Matthew is also concentrating in plant
breeding and genetics and after
graduation he plans to go to UC Berkeley
and study plant and microbial biology
there his presentation today is entitled
transgene pre editing of crop plants
Matthew alright can everyone hear me is
this working
works great we alright hello everyone my
name is Matthew Soares oh no it's and
today I'm gonna be presenting on my
research that I've been doing at the
plant transformation facility with
transgene free editing of crop plants so
this research is still ongoing and it's
been put on hold due to the pandemic so
I'm gonna break it down into the three
P's the premise the process and the
prospects of this research so the
premise is to develop a method of
transgene free editing of crop plants to
overcome prior regulatory constraints so
normally if you're using something like
CRISPR cast nine to add a genome you
will insert the DNA that encodes for the
Cassadine protein and then that plant
will become transgenic because it will
contain that DNA and when you're talking
about agriculture and trying to release
the crop under the market this becomes
rather problematic due to the immense
regulatory costs so we're something to
develop a method to edit a plant genome
with a directed edit without using any
incorporated DNA so why trans gene free
editing why is this so important so as I
mentioned there's a massive regulatory
cost that comes to any inserted DNA so
traditionally if you were to insert a
gene there would be about a 30 million
dollar price tag to go through the
regulatory process in the United States
and as you can imagine there are only a
pretty small number of players that can
actually afford that cost so it excludes
academic players small breeders NGOs and
the limit of potential stakeholders also
limits our potential to develop new and
better crops so there are new horizons
that are emerging with gene editing
technologies that can open up access to
this
editing tumult more players so the
million-dollar question becomes can we
create targeted edits without
introducing foreign DNA and the method
that my lab is trying to use to address
this question is induced direct control
editing by introducing certified
Cassadine protein and it's Jie RNA
template so rather than introducing the
DNA that encodes for cos 9 and then
allowing the plant to synthesize cussin
and edit we want to insert Cassadine
directly as a purified protein so that
there is no DNA so how do we go about
doing this there are two integral parts
of this method the first is to insert
that purified protein into a plant cell
and that's done with a gene gun and then
the second is to regenerate that edited
plant cell back into a full plans so
biolistic soar the gene gun I will walk
you through how this process works
i'mso to begin and box number one here
we take very very small gold particles
between 0.6 and 1.2 micrometers so if
microscopic crap you see here is a dust
and we precipitate a cassadine grna
complex onto the gold particle so he
effectively coat the surface of this
with protein traditionally with
ballistics you would use DNA and coat
them on the gold but since we don't want
DNA we're just taking the purified
protein product and painting each of
these gold particles with the protein we
then allow that to dry on these discs
and you can see here all of that gold
residue there's a nice powder and then
we load it into this machine and this is
the ballistics machine that actually
will shoot those golden bullets into
plant tissue so this works by inserting
these discs and then creating a vacuum
inside of this chamber with your plant
tissue and then you can select the
pressure that the gas will be introduced
into the chamber that will fire these
bullets into the plant tissue and so we
can choose between 350 and 2,100 psi so
quite a large range and the higher the
pressure the more force those bullets
will have and the deeper they'll
penetrate but also the more damage that
they will cause and then finally we'll
have you can see here these are some
wheat embryos and you can see that
there's some residual gold residue on
the embryos and so that's after it's
been fired and that's kind of the
general ballistics process but how do we
go about optimizing this process so
there are two main ways the first is how
do we optimize actually getting the gold
into the plan
tissue and we use agust constructs this
is DNA so it's just used to optimize and
essentially Gus is this marker that will
turn blue when you expose it expose
cells that contain Gus to a substrate so
you can see here all of these tiny blue
dots on the surface and that's every
cell that has received and successfully
expressed Gus and that's you can
quantify that so effectively we can look
at different pressures different number
of shots different sizes of goals on a
same type of plant tissue and then
quantify the number of blue dots and the
more blue dots we have the better we're
doing so we can use this to kind of
figure out what is the best combination
of variables to just introduce the gold
into the plant tissue and then the
second is we actually want to monitor
how well are we edited so to do this we
use we edit insert cast nine with a
guide RNA that edits the pds gene so PDS
is phyto induce a trace it is the gene
kind of at the top of the carotenoid by
the synthetic pathway and when we knock
it out a plant is no longer able to
produce carotenoids so when you expose a
plant without carotenoids to light it
will become photo bleached and they
appear as albino
so we can try different methods of
incubation or light versus dark
treatment with the cast on inside the
plant to monitor how well the editing is
occurring and we compare the ratio of
albino plans to green plants that are
regenerated and the higher that ratio is
the better we are doing in terms of
editing so you can see here this is kind
of a massive plant cells it's not
differentiated but this one appears to
be starting to grow some leaf like
structures and you can see how they are
white so it appears to be an edited leaf
and we can compare that to leaves that
develop it or green and find the ratio
between them so we try to optimize for a
higher ratio but as you can see here
this is not a plant this is just the
blob so how do we go from turning blobs
into plants and so that is what we the
main part of our work is tissue culture
so actually the process of turning
single cells back into plants it's a
very finicky process but throughout this
presentation you've seen all of these
plants kind of growing in a gel-like
substance so that gel is agar and inside
of that gel matrix there are a variety
of major minor salts planned vitamins
amino acids organic acids and plant
hormones and
these components work together to
dictate how a plant grows and we can
manipulate them to change plant growth
so as an example here on the Left this
is an aquatic plants that we were
experimenting on in class and it's grown
these are all identical media except for
plant hormones so we varied the ratio of
auxins cytokinins in the hormones and as
you can see it has a tremendous impact
on how a plant grows but hormones aren't
the only thing that I'm gonna move
myself once again I can't see uh here we
go are not the only thing that control
plant growth so all of these components
actually have a major impact on growth
as an example this is potato growing in
vitro and I only buried the amount of
sucrose so you can see and this is about
30 grams per liter of sucrose root
growth is robust and if you double that
you get an inhibition of your growth and
so it kind of follows a normalized
distribution so for a tissue culture in
general every single one of these
components every nutrient plays its own
role in plant physiology and development
and typically every species extranet
typically always every plant species has
its own very particular needs and then
within a species every variety so when
you're working even with two different
varieties of rice for instance they will
have their own media that they grow in
and they will not grow law in a
different media so a lot of this process
comes not only with optimizing the
editing procedure but then trying to get
plants back out from the editing so what
are these things look like when they're
done so I have some examples here that
I've been doing so this is a Chardonnay
grape that I was working on right before
I left you can see it's rooting it's
doing quite well
these are soybeans that I worked on over
the summer at a different Research
Institute they were doing soybean
research and then some apple that I was
doing also at Cornell one thing I want
to mention is this research with trans
gene for editing is particularly
important for clone early propagated
crops those things like grapes and
apples because you can't do a back cross
so for soybeans you could insert DNA and
then do a back cross to a wild-type to
remove that trans gene if you don't want
to trans gene in the final product but
if you want to preserve the characters
of things like Chardonnay or an apple
variety you can't do any crossing you
must clonally propagate it so any
inserted trans gene would be permanent
and so this
method of transgene free editing is
quite important for clearly propagated
craps which is why we're working on
apple and grape so what are the future
prospects and what are we going to try
to do so we wanted to continue
optimizing gold particle size the gun
pressure and excellent tissue which is
the type of tissue that we use for
transformation and we also want to
optimize our ability to select for
transform plans so that we can get as
many edited plants out of the process as
possible and then we're also starting
new research to test new technologies to
facilitate plant regeneration
so the ultimate goal of this research is
to produce an efficient affordable
transgene free editing platform and then
it's ma critized access to affordable
plan editing technologies to the public
sector
and with that I want to acknowledge the
team behind all the magic so again this
research is done in the Cornell plant
transformation facility and my p i-- is
dr. matthew women and thank you for your
attention Matthew Matthew who you've
seen like anything on acceptance of the
transgene free edited crops have you'd
like to talk to anybody about it it
seems like it could be really beneficial
right so there is one major product so
the company I actually have it here not
for this presentation I just haven't
have it so calyx which they produce
actually the soybean which is it used to
have a transient so the way they did
kind of the alternative approach where
you insert a transgene edit and then
back cross to remove a trans gene and so
they produced a high oleic soybean oil
and actually have some here so I worked
there over the summer and that's the
first ever gene edited product on the
market and it's been selling quite well
it is not labeled as gene edited so they
label that actually wasn't discussed in
class as non-gmo which is kind of
interesting but due to the way that
transgenics are regulated in the US if a
plant does not contain foreign DNA it's
actually considered to be done
transgenic and you can label it non-gmo
so I think as of now consumers perhaps
because they don't know but they seem
willing to consume it more so than
perhaps other transgenic products
other questions for Matthew Matthew can
you hold it
Kate likes product up again yeah nice
show-and-tell yeah you can't really see
I haven't different one too but uh well
that's a big joke this was a gal I know
this is like I don't know what I'm gonna
do with this I think it's more of like a
it's a memento what do you do with a
gallon of oil it's like the paperweight
I think you fried donuts and cheese
curds in it the oxy when I was there
they made so many cheese curds with it
and they were incredible I mean the
Minnesota and cheese curds except you
really should fried them in butter
mm-hmm just saying any other questions
our first talk this afternoon is from
Oakland Yann and he is concentrating in
plant genetics and plant physiology
after graduation his plans are I quote
to survive the pandemic and then study
at Rutgers University for graduate
school I'm sure and the Tyler Beanstalk
is located in the genic locust
associated with weeping phenotype in
Malus domestica talking about apple
blossoms alright hello everyone this is
how well yeah and I'm presenting my
research that I've been doing ever since
last summer in Geneva some background
information and like the overall goal of
the research so the reason why we did
the research is we believe that
understanding the apple tree
architecture can help us to improve the
uniformity of the apple trees and
therefore can potentially give us a
higher efficiency in production by
introducing something like mechanical
harvest services picking picking the
apples by hand so the goal of this
research particularly is to locate and
identify genes or
genes that are associated with the
weeping phenotype in the best apple
cheese which we will later refer to as
the WD locust so there have been
previous efforts done for this on this
direction on some other rosacea family
species such as peaches and crab apples
but none has been done in the domestic
level and this is over interested so
what is what is we can filter so as you
can see here in this comparison here the
weeping tree it the winking apple tree
is surely more dwarf and the branches
tend to twirl laterally and downwards
compared to the sender tree which is
security taller and the practice grow
upwards so it's pretty distinctive
pattern here so the method that we used
in this research particularly is that
first we phenotype half the population
which is the progeny of a heterozygous
hundreds I guess we can publish in open
pollinated and then we isolated DNA from
each single individual in that
population and then we constructed two
sets of DNA pause with those with those
DNA's one is the working pool one is the
standard pour so each composed of ten
DNA from that perspective phenotype and
we screen those DNA pause with various
SSR markers short simple repeat markers
throughout select from various parts of
the genome in order to see what if
there's it distinctive tired in between
the two sets of holes to see technically
whether there are potential genetic
linkage or not so if we see a petition
linkage we will further confirm it with
other with more individual DNA's and
more
wider range of dnas as well and after
that we will see if the pattern is also
true for the neighboring genetic markers
as well but if not we're just going to
keep repeating this process until we
find a positive linkage so the phenotype
your result is pretty interesting so
here in this diagram S stands for
standard s L stands for standard life
which is intermediate that's closer than
standard phenotype W stands for wicking
WL s looking like so we can see here is
that we have a number of intermediates
and that indicates the so the expression
of this phenotype is not directly linked
to one single gene so it's probably
other there are other factors that
actually play a role in expression of
this phenotype so the result for the for
the genetic analysis is so this is the
graph that I had for warming the marker
so for them so those are from each
individual line is from individual
that's in the waking pool or stand up or
so as you can see here in so this is the
band that were interested in what you
can see here 17 out of 19 in the weeping
population that we test it has this band
apart from these two and what only 1 out
of 19 in the standard 4 then we test it
has this ban so this is a very
distinctive parent that's been shown
here which in the case of very strong
genetic linkage and therefore what we
did next was to so the marker 2 was the
marker that was in the previous slide so
what we did is when we test it the
marker that our neighbor into it so
marker 1 marker 3 marker for and
we see here the recombination frequency
it is quite what we expect it actually
and is very beautiful
so marker 1 which is the upstream of
marker 2 has a higher recombination
frequency than marker 2 and which is
8.5% and marketer has like 2.8 percent
uh market 3 gets even lower which is
there's no recombination human but
present here a marker for like as it
goes further away from record to another
3 it gets higher again so this indicates
that market so that you know the locus
of interest is probably very close to
marker 3 here like okay so this genome
region is in the chromosome 13 and yeah
in a 140 45 KB region and also for the
standard control there's also a similar
pattern but the recombination event rate
is actually higher but it still follows
the same pattern as observed in a
wicking okay so in conclusion the WB
locus which is associated with the
working trade in Malus domestica
as we manage a genomic region of 945 KB
region on chromosome 13 of the of the
genome and based on the result from the
genotype there could be other genes also
the play a role as qualifying in fact so
for future research would what do we
been doing is we're gonna have finer
mapping of the region and also we're
going to analyze the RNA sequence to
determine like which exact genes
actually the cause of one yeah so so big
thanks to NSF grant corner community
summer Scholar Program
cannolis lab and my clan mates who help
during this research thanks for
listening question job thank you
so are there dozens or even more genes
in this 1945 KB interval so I think from
what I remember we kept the chains in
this region there like probably about 20
ish genes that yeah
within this region nothing obvious like
gym around yeah there are a few that are
related to hormones but we were not sure
at this point yet whether they are
actually the you know that to a closer
gene yet
you know we need a favor wait for the
RNA seek data to actually be sure nice
job thank you okay our next talk is from
lily and Trainor her concentration is
Ingenix breeding and pathology so a
mixed concentration after graduation
Lily will begin an advanced track
program through with the college and
Cornell to obtain an m-80 in biology and
agriculture education so great luck with
that the title of our presentation today
is evaluation of Plenty police garden
based learning programs thank you Mike
hello everyone this talk is based on a
study that was designed and performed by
Lily Cohen Audrey shoe attack Sarah
Scott Cruz Martha Williams and myself
tried a little bit of background about
this project it took place in the Toledo
district of Belize which is in the
southernmost region as pictured in the
map at the bottom right corner of the
screen this region is reliant on
subsistence slash-and-burn agriculture
pictured at the top of the screen due to
this in combination with an increase in
population the agricultural system is
becoming unsustainable this region is
primarily Mayan greif ona and creole
populations it also has many
impoverished and rural schools the
project we are evaluating is called the
gate project which is run through Puente
believes Gate stands for garden based
agriculture for Toledo's environment the
mission of this project is to address
environmental degradation and
unsustainable agriculture and poor
nutrition the goals of this project are
to create to create organic school
gardens that are replicable by the
communities enter organic gardening and
sustainable agriculture this project has
develop programs over 40 schools though
not all of these Gardens have been
successful Crennel first became involved
in this project through marcia and
chiefly in 2009 students traveled to
Belize for the first time and for many
years after that they traveled there to
create Gardens
give lessons to students and train
teachers on how to incorporate the
curriculum into the garden 2019 the year
that I went was the first year that
students conducted an evaluation this
image was taken at Bob's Bible School
which is in the Toledo district
pronounce names comm goals of
involvement involve par meet goals and
involvement include creating an unbiased
evaluation and suggesting next steps for
the project as it was in the concluding
phases and they're wondering what worked
what didn't work and what they should do
next the top left image was at one of
the first schools we visited which had a
very successful garden program they
allowed to harvest produce from the
gardens and then they serve that to us
for our lunch our methods included
traveling to schools conducting
interviews focus groups and surveys the
top left image here is an interview that
we conducted with Don who was a member
of the punty beliefs board as well as a
member of the PTA for one of the schools
that we are evaluating
our interviews were primarily conducted
with principals teachers and community
members while we did focus groups for
students and women's groups these
interviews and focus groups focused on
topics such as support and resources
nutrition challenges and sustainability
relationships and a few other topics
that we identified as important for the
evaluation as you can see from the
images on this slide
most of our interviews took place in
either the garden or greenhouse setting
we provided surveys to younger
elementary youth and these surveys
consisted of statements with a response
scale of strongly agree to strongly
disagree checkboxes as well as some
visual responses such as what is
pictured on this slide the reason we
chose these formats is because not all
students were fluent in English and most
of these were easy to interpret this
would likely lead to more accurate
responses we did also include a few open
response questions so that students
could provide more detail as they were
able to
our observations refer to what we
directly saw and heard when they travel
to the schools some highlights of our
observations include the support for
these programs worked well particularly
the interactions and frequent site
visits by plenty police staff were
valuable to the schools we noticed how
important it was for integrate for the
curricular subjects we integrated into
the garden space this is because many
teachers are already stressed by trying
to meet the demands of standardized
testing and don't see how they can fit
one more thing into their day showing
teachers how their current subjects can
be incorporated into the garden space is
essential and may contribute to helping
them adopt the program we also noticed
that some schools were only addressing
topics such as nutrition or science in
the garden while other schools were
addressing those in addition to topics
such as English and math using these
gardens for more subjects increases the
success of them and likelihood the
teachers will adopt them the bottom-left
photo here is a project that students
did for recycling and they managed to
recycle bottles to build garden beds our
interpretations refer to how we
understood what we observed and how we
connected it to a larger picture our
highlights of our interpretations may be
divided into overall support and the
value of the program community support
is essential an ownership through
participation of the community and a
variety of ways was found to greatly
contribute to the success of programs
women's groups were an important
resource for some gardens and they
benefit both the schools as well as the
women because it provides some of the
source of income and the skills to grow
their own food
parental support is encouraged by
academic success some parents only see
the value in traditional academic
learning and don't understand how
gardening fits into that by
demonstrating to parents how the gardens
can be used to teach traditional
subjects they're more likely to support
the garden program
community partnerships were found to
strengthen the sustainability of the
garden by providing continual support
despite possible turnover and staff at
the schools
additionally we realize how important it
was for the success of programs to have
the support of the staff in the schools
one standard for teachers stated that
teachers need to be invested you can
pump schools full of supplies but the
garden will fail if people are not
invested we discovered for the value
that the garden involvement contributed
to positive youth development such as
belonging generosity independence and
collaboration school gardens also
contribute to food security for both the
students in the school as well as
community members one teacher captured
this well when he stated that what
really amazed him was when a needy child
was eating what they grew and without
this project that child would have a
hungry day other teachers commented on
how much better behaved and better
focused students were when they were not
hungry because they were receiving
nourishment through the garden program
from our observations and our
interpretations we developed a set of
recommendations which included
professional development community
engagement partnerships a strategic plan
needs assessment and further evaluation
for professional development we decided
to focus on teachers plenti beliefs
should hold workshops for teachers that
explain why Gardens matter and also
convey garden knowledge such as pest
management and composting hopefully if
teachers can see the importance of the
gardens and the beneficial impact they
can have and also have the confidence to
manage the gardens these programs would
become more independent and less reliant
on support from plenty believes the
image on the right is a pest management
systems designed by students they read
that spreading grease on blue plastic
would attract the bugs and then they
would stick there and this would keep
pests away from their plants the top
image is a composting system if one of
the schools that was not being used
because many teachers do not know how to
compost we discovered that the Community
Learning could be incorporated into the
greenhouses and garden spaces if the
school's hosted community workshops on
topics such as organic agriculture and
the community was able to directly
participate in the garden this would
likely increase their support for the
program women's groups
a valuable resource because they could
tend to the garden over school breaks
when students could not come in we also
thought it would be beneficial for them
to partner with colleges such as Bob's
Bible School which I mentioned earlier
which has a very successful horticulture
program pictured here on the right
students involved in this program could
lead workshops for the school programs
on topics such as building gardens and
managing them
we discovered that many schools were not
receiving the resources they needed
while other schools were receiving
resources they did not need an example
of this is one school that needed seeds
and another school that had plenty of
seeds but needed better quality soil we
suggest that they develop an application
to ensure that resources are going where
they are most needed and this will
contribute to sustainability by the
using resources to their optimal
potential in the middle of the slide
here is a picture of a school that was
able to obtain its own resources and
we're using them to their full potential
and the top is a school that was given a
lot of resources but they weren't able
to use all the resources that they were
given a strategic plan would enable
punty believes to solidify the core
values vision and mission in order to
determine how to best about staff and
board time and efforts
well the main focus on my talk is the
study it wouldn't be complete without
discussing the story behind the study
this experience was filled with
challenges such as that some of the
people we interviewed spoke literal
little or no English had a few
participants did not show up to our
interviews additionally for me
personally it was a challenge to adapt
to the environment food and housing
conditions due to a lack of things I
would consider necessities such a
lecture such as electricity running
water and clothes sleeping spaces and
dairy products
I was also bitten by so many ants that I
thought I was going to lose my mind
despite these challenges this experience
was filled with many adventures such as
breathtaking nature cultural immersion
the opportunity to fly a plane at this
picture in the top right corner and so
much more I would like to offer a
special thanks to our faculty Mentors
Marcia and Steve Lee and Fiona Daugherty
who were so supportive through this
process and absolutely instrumental to
the success of this evaluation and
that's all I have so what questions do
you have for me
so literally can you speak to the school
garden movement in the United States I
know for a while there is a lot of
interest California is going to mandate
that for all the school districts oh is
that still sort of an initiative around
the country so I'm not familiar with
what's going on in California it's
definitely increasing I know even in my
home school at in New York they recently
developed a community gardening project
in collaboration with the schools and I
am seeing on the New York State
coordinator for the National National
Junior Master Gardener program and so
through that I'm kind of connected on
the national scale to what's going on
and I'm definitely seeing an increase
and more interest in this and I think
one thing like that national that the
mgmg program is doing is that they're
developing school curricula in
coordination with state mandates so that
it can be implemented into the garden
and I think that is really contributing
to these programs being adapted in the
u.s. thanks okay great job Sibella magna
unity our concentration is plant
breeding in genetics and applied plant
science after graduation Isabella will
be working for professor caret Cox and
then applying for admission to graduate
school in the fall of 2021 for title of
our presentation today is how do we test
thrips resistance
Izabella see your slides ok perfect so
hi like Mike said my name is Isabella
Magni and you see and I'm today I'm
going to be talking about the research I
conducted in summer 2019 looking at how
we test thrips resistance so I briefly
want to talk about what trips are so
there's small insects you can see over
here the larvae and the adults they're
in the order Theissen Optra and in this
particular study we looked at onion
thrips or thrips tabacky and the reason
we looked at them is because in New York
State which ranks seven the National
onion production they can cause between
30 and 50% crop losses an onion
production New York State is also value
between 40 and 50 million dollars
so they can cause extreme economic
distress for farmers across the state
we've three main objectives for this
study we wanted to understand how
insecticide exposure affects thrips
mortality we had a contact assay a
feeding assay and a contact and feeding
assay in addition to a field simulation
we designed we wanted to determine which
assay most accurately represents field
rates because we wanted to create a link
between laboratory experiments and
actual field conditions and we wanted to
discover which assay was the most simple
to execute so if we want to make these
sorts of recommendations to crop
consultants and other scientists we need
to be able to explain how simple and
easy the methods were to actually
execute so we looked at four bio assays
in the study the first being tibs which
stands for thrips insecticide bioassay
system and this was a contact only assay
where we coated the inside of different
test tubes with different pesticide
concentrations left them to dry and then
incorporated the thrips we then looked
at a feeding assay where instead of
through contact the pesticide was
introduced through the feeding solutions
with herps were only coming into contact
with it through ingestion our third
bioassay was a leaf dip which was a
combination of a contact and a feeding
assay where we took cabbage discs and
soaked them in different pesticide
solutions we then dry them off and
introduced them to these petri dishes
with drips and the reason that we use
cabbage disks instead of onion leaves
ewwww because we were looking at onion
thrips is because onions have pretty
thin and small leaves and we wanted to
ensure that there was consistency
throughout the different replications of
his bioassay lastly we designed and
conducted a field simulation where we
grew onion plants in the greenhouse and
then separated them into these different
groups and apply different pesticide
concentrations frase so the results of
this experiment were super interesting
the feeding assay over here on the
bottom the leaf dip in the middle in
magenta and tips up here in blue this is
the log dose mortality curve with
mortality on the y-axis and log dose in
parts per million on the x-axis and the
Elsi 50s which is the concentration at
which 50% of the insect population was
dying off was statistically different
for all three laboratory bio assays
which is very interesting because all
three of these are readily used in the
literature and you may notice that the
field simulation is not
on this graphic and that's because when
we used our probit analysis with the
data from the field simulation it did
not generate a curve unfortunately so
our feeding si had the highest lc50
which means it took the most amount of
pesticide to kill a 50% of the
population and is interesting because it
shows that contact is a really important
part of the pesticides mode of action
and this idea is further supported by
the fact that leaf the leaf tip had the
smallest lc50 and tips had the highest
mortality at low concentration so where
contact was incorporated into the bio si
the threats were much more sensitive to
the amount of pesticide being applied
takeaways from the study the feeding
assay was by far the easiest to set up
it required the least amount of
resources and time and it was very easy
to check on the thrips and assess
mortality and again suggest that contact
is an important part of how pesticides
work at killing off Terps populations
tim's was definitely the most
complicated it required a lot of time a
lot of resources and a lot of waiting
also because you have to make sure that
the pesticide is coating the inside of
the test tube effectively and again we
would just need more replications of the
field simulation in order to
definitively conclude which laboratory
bioassay most accurately represents
field conditions i would like to thank
cornell Agrotech and cornell cows the
Geneva Summer Scholars program for
funding this project and hewan Silva for
the code for the probit analysis we used
to analyze this data it was extremely
helpful and I really want to thank Eric
I'm already and Brian Nault who were
instrumental in helping me come up with
this project and supporting me
throughout these are all of my resources
and I'd be happy to take any questions
you may have thank you do you think it
would be difficult Isabella - to
eventually turn one of these into
something that could be done quickly so
that it could inform inform growers free
practices yes I do so I actually gave
this talk yesterday to the entomology
department and I had 10 minutes I was
able to explain a little bit more but
even though the field simulation didn't
fit our probit analysis the lc50 it
generated was most simple
to that of the feeding assay so that's
what we would recommend right now just
because of the information and the
results we have from the study but
that's what we're hoping is that there
was there's a quick and effective way
for everybody the growers Extension
agents farmers to check their thrips
population and test the resistance
levels other questions comments okay
beautiful job okay our next presenter is
linghua Wayne her concentration is Plant
Pathology and after graduation she'll
continue that studying right here at
Cornell NPP PMB and our talk today is
entitled molecular differences between
tomato immune receptors FL s2 and fls
3-way well guys i'm leway one today i
want to talk about the project between
Alice tuna anniversary so the project is
about the tomato PSD Pat assistant est
send for the Pseudomonas arranger
passive our tomato it is a bacterial
pathogen which lead to the bacterial
spec disease in many Solanaceae species
including tomato it causes a huge loss
in the tomato production in New York
State
the pellet is then served as a model for
studying bacterial pathogenesis and
applying mmunity the effort of the
project is to understand interaction in
the molecular level which can help us to
better understand that plan unity and
possibly help us to find new resistance
at the end the pathogen which can help
us to control the disease a necklace two
and F of three staff or for Joe and
sensing - and for those things and three
the reason why were used in this topic
is that both efforts to and n3 play an
important role in community and they are
similar in many ways however the
individual contribution to the
resistance is still unknown to us so
they are both pattern recognition
receptors and responds to different
peptide i'm PST for Jolyon so which is F
for John 22 and for John 2:28 and they
are both receptor like kindnesses which
means stay regulate the pathways
phosphorylation and give you a mindset
that they have the property as a kinase
and upon the recognition of Sajal and
the immune response implants will be
triggered including the roster spots
Roth stands for the reactive oxygen
species a rapid and transit first of
Ross is a key response of plants and in
the lab condition we can detect its
production quickly with the treatment of
in our cases for ten twenty two and four
thousand to twenty eight so the more
Ross production could be an indicator of
higher immune response and the start of
our project is a very interesting
observation you know Rasta huh so the
x-axis stands for the time after we add
in the peptide and the y-axis is our US
production as show here the Ross my
stands for F was three is more sustained
than the Ross response of efforts to if
we expand the time a little bit efforts
to will response for about 100 minutes
well efforts to will only response for
sixty minutes and the structure of the
receptor has show here including three
domains so which is the kinase domain is
inside of the cell and the transmembrane
domain and the loser rich repeat to me
we Hippolytus that the kindness property
of those two receptor contribute to the
Ross difference so will align a sequence
of the kinase domain and find that alpha
stood and at most we share a common
license which involving ATP binding
process is an important step in the
phosphorylation and after three share a
condom Cassandra Schmoe tip which is gxg
access G motive this motif has been
shown to have an enhanced kinase
activity other kinase family
so we hypothesize that this motif would
keep enhance kinase activity to so3 as
well which could possibly be the reason
for the difference in response so it
built four different constructs to test
our hypothesis first would replace the
licen and lead to a loss of kinase
activity in both efforts to and F of
three we use it as an active control in
our following process a and then we'll
replace the guys enriched motif in F of
three with with his counterpart in
office to wishes which is a G
as access as motive and make Elvis tube
mutate to have a white and rich motive
the kindness si support our hypothesis
said the guys are rich motive did result
in the increase in kinase activity so
the next step is to see whether the
increased kinase activity is the reason
for the different response this to
figure here shown the total rows
production of our to four construct and
the wild-type so the loss of kinase
activity in this to construct did show a
loss of Ross response surprisingly the
efforts to mutation result in a decrease
of total Ross production rather than an
increase for the efforts mutation we
observe no significant effect of the
mutation of the total Ross production so
the resources asta although the guys
Irish motif influence the initial kinase
activity the differences in kinase
activity along does not explain the
differences in the Ross outfit between
those two receptors
it is currently unknown to us why the
initial result do not translate to the
implant Arase say for future experiments
studying the kinase activity we will
will help us uncover the mechanism of
kinase activation levels through an
alpha 3 and the project as a whole
suggests no single domain of other
student ancestry including the our
domain transmembrane domain and kinase
domain can explain the sustained
response in l3 and multiple structure
features unique to FL 3 might contribute
to the sustained response and it's very
I'm know whether F of 3 can function in
species outside the southern AC but
future efforts to express our 3 more
diverse species who determine whether
Sun is a specific protein partners I
involved in the Alpha 3 dose response
and in and a lot of thanks to the PF the
lab reporting and the member of our
project team Robin Roberts and Alex
Ville and all my members who helped me
during a summer and here's my reference
I'm glad to take any comments and
questions
lots of time for comments a beautiful
job we're sophisticated thank you okay
our next talk is from Jessie Jo her
concentration is computational biology
after graduation
Jessie plans to go get a job from IQ BIA
which is a pharmaceutical manufacturing
law firm in China and at elaborate talk
today is maize genome prediction with
human based RNA splicing models hello
everyone today I'm going to talk about
maize genome prediction listed a human
based RNA splicing model first I like to
send my thanks to all members of the
pergola I've worked at Burgos labs in
the summer of 2009 t like black group
has developed a wide range of data about
implements and molecular tools for plant
genetics and diversity studies the boss
of our lab is at West Berkeley
he's the research genetics mister
usda-ars the drunked professor of plant
breeding and genetics at Cornell
University and he sauce sole member of
National Academy of Sciences to begin
with I'd like to briefly introduce our
lab tradition and a hackathon basically
it's an annual activity that all that
members and traveling scholars work
together for certain project and the
project for 2019 was studying KP I
wasn't into and our team focused on
studying keeping models our team leader
is Catherine and she's an expert at
building plant models and she really
taught me a lot of things and I want to
send my special thanks to her so first
what's keeping KP is in an IPA and an
repository he is ready to use tree
models for genomics it offers a quick
and easy way to share these models no
matter you prefer using our Python
all come online when we check their
models who we found at the most popular
popular tests and keeping is the RNA
splicing tag so
we don't we decide to have take a deeper
take a closer look at this one and to
find out like why RNA splicing is so
important so first what's RNA splicing
basically it's an newly made mRNA
transform into a tour MRA during this
process intron and removed so that
excellence can connected with each other
due to the time limitation to RNA
I would just introduce one RNA splicing
models here and it's Optimus Phi Prime
and it's human base which targets the
five prime untranslated region my prime
UTR is the region is the region of an
mRNA that's directly upstream from the
initiation codon and this primary
determinant of translation efficiency in
other words it's quite important for RNA
splicing and also the translation so
here comes the question what if we
predict the maze with a human model to
recently do so that there's no plan
based model turn based RNA splicing
model on key P and also the optimist
fight crime seems to be robust like
according to the high accuracy dimension
in its paper and also if the model can
help we can then build an RNA splicing
splicing model for plans using this
model and if it cannot help them here we
found a gap so what we do first is that
we go to them hdtb gathering the maize
genome files and try to compare the
prediction result with the human premium
human make problem file
provide pride from KP and we submit our
Python script on the bitbucket and here
is the result this apply shows the
cumulative distribution of MRLs of
Optimus Prime and we can see that and
Mase here has the higher has a sharper
has a sharper
distribution cook and the mace also has
a higher mean median and Max comparing
wasting humans however the optimist
five-prime paper suggests that a mean
and median mr arrow should be like
around 7 but all these they're just
around 5 and 6 so so this is not so
ideal then we decide to take a closer
closer look at the prediction we use igb
to visualize the results and the upper
table is the reference genome ace
reference Jena and the lower one nest
without prediction result of optimist
Phi Prime and the first figure shows the
correct condition it's that atmosphere
prime did find the Phi prime utrs at a
right position and lens is also very
good and figure 2 shows that it final
didn't find a correct Phi prime UTR
Kirstin lesson like too long for the 5
prime material but it got a right
position here I just choose to
representative results and a whole
visualized prediction of maze Phi prime
UTR is very messy so it suggests that
the differ from you TR have a kind of
low accuracy I'm finding an amazed by
prime UTR so the gate did exist and a
human model cannot predict cannot be
useful prediction for maize genome and
this is the references and thanks for
attention and no questions
okay thanks very much that was great
our next talk is from Martha Williams
her concentration is in ecology of
managed landscapes and after graduation
Cornell she will attend NYU Steinhardt
MA food studies program part-time in the
fall the title of Martha's talk is
garden based learning at Cornell
Cooperative Extension Nassau County
[Music]
thank you for the introduction so this
is actually about my three consecutive
summers at Cornell Cooperative Extension
in Nassau County so first I'm gonna give
some definitions then I'm gonna tell you
a little bit about the place where
actually worked and then I'm gonna talk
about the garden piece learning programs
and challenges and outcomes so what is
Cornell Cooperative Extension land-grant
universities and colleges to provide
non-formal and environmental and
agricultural education so in New York
State that's different extension offices
in each 62 counties that is really
focused on helping New York State
families and communities thrive so
kwinto card makes learning is another
way of really achieving that mission and
those goals within it so the focus of my
work was really to engaged to empower
and provide relevant experiences to the
youth that I was teaching so each little
part and each little farm is rendered
the most of my teaching I are there
again to promote the CCE mission they
have demonstration gardens like you can
see up here and they also had a
farmstead on Fridays throughout the
summer and also about the Falls and
right here is actually some of the the
produce that we actually collected
during that time that we're growing by
the Master Gardener volunteers which is
just a group of people who come in
volunteering it a lot of expert
knowledge on gardening and growing
things they also have classes they have
plant diagnostics right here is an
example
the farm animals there her name is Tilly
and she's also really evil so you can't
trust her okay so the gardens based
learning programs so I said seeds a
salad and 2017 the summer and then I did
junior Master Gardeners for two
consecutive summers and I also did a lot
of one-off lessons and just gardening
basics and the right here is actually
example of some microgreens a group was
growing for one of those lessons so
program and objectives for a seeds of
salad so really the focus of this is to
utilize small space which is actually
right here on this picture below is
actually a picture of something growing
in a small space garden which is one of
the demonstration gardens at East Meadow
Farm and we actually use that as one of
the models for creating the smaller
space garden they they gain the basic
horticultural skills they are able to
engage and multi this they're using
their age and things I had to do with
English as writing and things of that
nature so it's not just purely science
like when people think about when they
hear garden based learning or really any
other type of really like varying focus
curriculum of any sort so up here in
this left photo up top is actually one
of the things that I created with for
this group that was doing this seeds a
solid program so it was actually a way
for them to interact more with something
physically in front of them though they
can rate so there's something like
learning about growing problems they
would grow so they would draw something
like what does the plant look like if it
was in this type of condition and then
also being able to talk about beneficial
organisms like what's going on in the
space around them and what's actually
helping those plants grow and then they
would write about that so they actually
have this journaling activity so again
bringing English arts into the garden
space and also this particular program
is very centred on youth decision-making
so it's all about the youth having the
opportunity to to to things and make
those final decisions themselves and
these youth from like four to six years
old
Junior master gardeners in this program
is a little bit higher in terms of the
level of information but also this the
children that are involved are really
the youth are from ages 14 to they're
like 13 to 16 so they're developing
gardening skills as the seeds a salad
program does
they're also learning a lot more about
scents and not just that you put a seed
in the ground and it grows but like what
goes into that how does it actually
develop like what is it what does it
look like on a cellular level even
understanding the basis of ecology so
understanding that plants just don't
grow magically but there are probably
the larger system and that they're
contributing to this to other organisms
that are growing there like in the soil
whether the animals the birds whatever
also learning just the basics of
designing a garden so why do you plant
anything where you plant it you know
making sure the soil is correct so doing
site assessments but also knowing that
there's a lot of shade in this area or
how can we make it more beautiful and up
here is actually a picture of one of the
beam plants that they were growing for
look at for one of the junior Master
Gardener classes they also engage in a
lot of hands-on activities so you can
actually see down here is not one of the
junior Master Gardener classes they like
to pool a lot of the same kinds of
learning objectives from the junior
masters gardening programs and some a
one-off lessons but this is actually at
a day camp that I visited with another
Master Gardener volunteer and they were
using a lot of those skills as well so
there are a lot of challenges and
planning these programs there's a lot of
them were were made for entire academic
years and I had to fit them into a few
weeks of the summer so timing was a
really big challenge with them that also
another challenge the timing was being
able to make sure that I could adapt a
lot when people would show up later than
expected or they came earlier than
expected and really having to think on
my toes in that sense there are also
diverse and region so actually in this
particular group here that you is
pictured there's people from link like
12 to 17 that's like a really large age
group and even though we broken up
between my supervisor and myself it was
still like a lot to handle so actually
trying to make things that it felt like
they were being challenged the older
individuals that the younger people also
didn't feel like they were being
overexerted and I think we were trying
to teach them too much and giving the
older youth an opportunity to teach the
younger youth also limited resources
they didn't always have all the things
that we needed like the seeds
necessarily didn't come on time or me
know
gloves wouldn't always have travels and
also we didn't always have
transportation to get people back and
forth so really having to be creative
with that but then also teaching the
youth that hey even if you don't have
all the things that you need you can
still grow things so that was a learning
experience for myself as well as the
youth also language barriers again with
this group here there is a one student
in particular who didn't know any
English so he actually had to work with
her to figure out how to communicate
different things to her and had a
student sometimes translate things to
her and it worked out fairly well I
think she seemed to be smiling I hope
that's because she was learning
okay program outcomes so throughout all
these programs they were able to connect
with the natural world because so often
we have these experiences where we feel
as though we are one thing in nature is
another program these programs really
allowed to bridge that gap so down here
actually in this picture below there
were a bunch of students there who
didn't really want to touch soil but I
was showing them like oh no the soil is
great and there's nothing to be scared
about in their worms and what are you
finding the soil and really seeing them
connect with something that was not
human or not electronic learning how to
plan build and maintain a garden space
if you see in this upper left photo
right here this is actually a group of
students physically drawing out their
gardens that they know where things
should go and if anything didn't look
right they can just change it before
actually putting something in the ground
so again that idea of planning before
you actually do something so not waste
time or resources also bonding with
their peers so in this upper right
corner you see that their two sister two
groups of sisters and they ended up
becoming friends throughout the course
of the program also bridging the gap
between people and food production
because right now so many people there
or or they get the diversity in order to
them because it's co-ed and the idea of
being able to to know where your food
comes from and be able to grow it
yourself it was something that is very
novel to a lot of people and up here you
actually see some of the girls that are
eating these different things brewing
their own garden and although you can
see one of them is not particularly
happy about all the things that we grew
they were able to eat a lot more
vegetables than they normally would have
because they grew themselves so there
isn't and like inherent
disgust for vegetables or anything but
really it's a matter of how connected
are you to your food so speaking of
people I would like to acknowledge those
who were really important in my
experiences during the summer so I my
supervisor who's pictured on the left
here the farm stand manager who I worked
with every Friday and Saturday the IT
coordinator holds me a lot with
advertising things the Master Gardener
volunteers who taught me a lot about
different gardening things I myself
didn't even know the executive director
who was very instrumental in getting me
back there every summer but I've been
forestry educator who taught me a lot
about trees and just like woody plants
generally which was awesome and the food
systems nutrition team later because she
was there to help me get to places
physically but also she had lessons that
coincided with my granny's learning
programs so thank you so much for your
questions we have hi if it's okay if I
asked one this is Chelsea hi Martha
great job that was a fantastic
presentation thank you and it's so great
to see all the visuals that go along
with all the work that you did in the
over the summers I was wondering how do
you know how many other of these card
based learning programs are going on
linked throughout New York State with
our Cooperative Extension I can't tell
you an exact number but I know that from
my experience working with different
people in different extensions that they
do their like own versions of grande
based learning programs they also do
them in schools but I don't have the
exact number it seems like this would be
a great program to sort of coordinate
because you have a lot of lessons
learned that is with with resilience and
and team-based learning and things that
that I could imagine expanding to a lot
of communities and yeah being part of
that it's actually funny easy that
because right now I'm working with
the people who was really really
important and my entire experience is my
shaking she mentioned earlier because
I'm working with her to curate a program
called seed she's so supper but with
youth groups so it's a program that
already exists for adults but this is
you this one is more focused on youth
and also integrating concepts of social
justice and voice and personal agency as
well as gardening and co-op
collaboration and leadership so that
idea of learning putting together all
the things that I've learned and all the
things that already exist in these
awesome programs and just bringing them
up to date and making sure that we're
considering the intersectionality of
these issues that so many different
groups are facing within their own
communities wonderful well these types
of programs are gonna be important now
more than ever as communities are
feeling fragmented so thank you for all
your work on this is great thank you
yeah I just took quite question hi
Martha it's Adrian hey it's so great to
see your work really great talk um I was
wondering if you were explicitly and I'm
you know what taking any measurable
outcomes I know it could be really hard
across such a wide like age of children
and teens you were working with but were
you and of explicitly measuring any
outcomes yeah so of the objectives that
were present for each of those different
programs they I wanted to see like
different types of surveys and whatnot
and I did get a glimpse of that and I
had different students that would submit
different comments that they had about
the different programs that were
happening but I didn't have a lot of
quantitative data it was also really
hard to follow up with all the groups
because again like the chaos of the
summer I working on a place that's
really made for gardening and so the
best time to deal with gardening for
that particular group especially when
people are actually available is the
summer time so I had like so many
different things going on that I didn't
have like a enough comprehensive data to
put into a presentation but it's
definitely something that I definitely
want to work on more and when I continue
this kind of work especially with the
work I'm doing now is the seed to supper
great cool great thanks thank you
Regina your hand is raised go ahead I'm
eatin go ahead hi sweet throughout the
years and I love you very much I don't
know if there's much gardening but I
wanted to be online with this okay
thanks a lot Martha great job thank you
our last talk today is from Yahoo Jean
her concentration is in computational
biology after graduation from Cornell
she will attend Southwestern Medical
Center for a PhD study to talk today is
entitled this CI tf1 mediated regulatory
network of copper homeostasis in a rabid
abscess thaliana alright thank you Mike
for the introduction hi everyone I'm
very happy to share with you my honors
thesis project join dr. Olin about manic
sloth which is about the safer mediating
regulatory network of copper homeostasis
in Vienna so copper is an important
micronutrients in many biological
processes including respiration for the
synthesis and reproduction so that it is
essential for the growth and development
of all organisms including plants copper
deficiency can videos plant growth
fertility and the accurate cases will
cause total crop failure meanwhile
excessive copper is also toxic so the
precise regulation of copper homeostasis
is important to identifying normal
transcription factors that regulate
copper homeostasis previous work el dr.
Batman X lab analyzed the responses of
the flower transcriptome to copper
deficiency by our ASIC and among the up
regulated transcription factors the
expression of a previously anchor with
horizon
of pho each family was regulated to the
highest level
so we characterize this transcription
factor and they made safe one and here
I'm gonna show some further
investigation our house if one works at
protein level in addition to these
transcriptional studies firstly I tested
why they're safe one responses to copper
availability at the protein level so I
collected plant issues from my rosette
slaves and rose on the cap rate
efficient versus copper sufficient
conditions and the total protein was
upgraded into certain solid fraction and
the nuclear fraction to check is
subcellular compartments asian we can
see the CFM protein is upregulated in
cytosolic part under copper deficient
conditions which indicates if one may
have important function under copper
deficiency and if the copper is
sufficient the plant may want to remove
SIF one to shut down the copper
deficiency response genes so next we
want we wanted to check if c1 is under
this kind of control at protein level
whence if one is sufficient and our
hypothesis aids if one protein might be
degraded under copper sufficient
condition so to further confirm if
excessive copper can accelerate safe one
turnover CH X which is a translation
inhibitor was used to block further
protein production before copper
treatment so we can compare the
degrading speed of the existing safe one
protein so based upon Sajak's treatment
they exist in safe were safe while was
degraded much faster under excessive
copper concentration compared to control
condition which does not have copper
treatment therefore we can confirm that
a turnover rate of safe one could be
accelerated under copper sufficient
condition then we want to know what
happened when cap rate is sufficient it
should be go through some degradation
pathway and one common degradation
mechanism in cell was the Proteus
immediately
pathway so to test whether the protein
stone degradation pathway was involved
in safe one turnover depending upon
copper availability mg 132 was used so I
Inc ability to save on transgenic plants
with mg 132 which is a protein so
inhibitor and the result shows CFM
protein accumulated when treated with mg
132 or the other word when the protein
so activity was inhibited which means if
one was degraded by proteasome
so to summarize all these fundings
cyclamen plays important roles when
copper is was deficient and if the
copper was sufficient silver will be
degraded through the protein so mediated
pathway and here is a diagram of this
working model and i would like to
express my gratitude to all my lab
numbers and my mentor dr. olin about
manic and mighty records supervisor dr.
wujin sia and all the funding resources
that supported my research thank you all
for being here and listening and I'm
happy to take questions
rosemary has a question
No okay you showed up there any
questions
great job very good job boy thanks
everyone
all of our students for doing a
fantastic job under a very challenging
situation you did a fabulous fabulous
symposium I'll put your video back on
yeah it's great to see you all
okay any any closing comments anyone I
think we should should thank Mike and
Chris for allowing this to happen and
advising everybody in their
presentations and being great mentors I
think indeed thank you both so much
thank you thank you this is a favorite
class to teach
it's great and we hope to be in contact
when the university decides what we're
all gonna do for graduation right I
would note that at our high point we had
over 50 people zooming in to hear you
all so that was great thanks for
everybody who attended for all the great
questions yeah welcome Thanks thanks
everyone Cheers
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu